as humans
we run scenarios in our heads all the
time
trying to predict how our actions might
play out but the only way to test our
theories
is to take action in the real world
what if we could accurately simulate the
world
try different actions in parallel
realities perhaps thousands of times
see the consequences and then go back
and try again
we have some microsoft folks joining us
for the call today so keith works for
microsoft meg works for microsoft
scott stanfield works for microsoft i
just want to make it clear that this is
their personal opinions
we haven't revealed any confidential
information this is not intended to be a
sales pitch for bonsai i don't work for
microsoft anymore so i'm
certainly not under any obligation to
give a sales pitch and enjoy the show
can you just put a second ball on it i
just want to see what happens you'll
laugh
[Music]
well it's keeping one up there so it's
it's just
it's almost disregarding one
oh whoa okay what happens if you put
both on at the same time
[Music]
yeah it does that thing it sort of
knocks them both off
yeah think about it gets confused
well this is this is a wonderful
anecdote for machine learning in general
because you train a model to do a task
and then you wonder why when you give it
something completely different
it's not completely different it's just
a generalization
hey meg how's it going hey tim i'm doing
good in you
i'm doing very well thank you very much
so i'm megan bloomsman
i'm a cloud solution architect working
for microsoft living in the netherlands
but i'm traditionally a data scientist
it's what i've been trained on it's what
i got my masters in
that's how we know each other yeah so
from the netherlands and uh
very excited to be here and finally put
my brain to work about some machine
teaching
amazing yeah so meg and i met each other
a few years ago
at microsoft we were partners in crime
and today is a pretty cool day because
microsoft have sent me one of these
project
moabs it's an impressive looking device
isn't it
it's beautiful yeah so this project moab
it's um
as you can see it's a piece of hardware
with uh
well it's basically a plate with a ping
pong ball and what tim is doing seems
pretty easy
sorry good timing
so this is the project moab which is
basically a piece of hardware that has a
plate on it and a ping pong ball
and what this piece of hardware has done
is you can
teach it how to balance the ping pong
ball
so as you can see tim is kind of not
just placing it on it but throwing it on
there and
the plate will balance itself out to
make sure the ball doesn't fall off
what i think is really interesting about
this is and i told
tim this as well is i show this to my
parents and i'm super excited about this
and they just weren't really getting
into why this is so exciting
what if before taking an action in the
real world
the autonomous agent took thousands of
actions
in a parallel reality looked at the
outcome of those actions
and then selected the best action to
take in the real world
microsoft bought a company called bonsai
in 2018
it was a san francisco-based startup
focusing on platformitizing
deep reinforcement learning moving away
from games and into real-world
applications
being able to optimize physical
processes and systems
reinforcement learning is a bit
different to traditional machine
learning
in the sense that we're learning by
exploring
an environment and we don't know the
actual answers to our predictions
while we're training you know we often
hear that being able to monitor
and maintain things using ai is is a
good thing but
i suppose what bonsai want to do is move
into the realm of being able to optimize
and automate
physical processes there are four killer
problems in deep reinforcement learning
ladies and gentlemen
one reward sparsity two deceptive search
spaces
three generalization and four
sample efficiency this is what's coming
in today's presentation
yeah but i i want to know what the magic
is because there is no magic
no that's what i was thinking too it's
it's as it's as if somebody said
yeah you know you're doing these old
school linear fits and you're throwing
in the data and you're calculating all
these like
error squares and everything what if i
could just come give you two numbers
a slope and an intercept and you could
get the solution from this
is a hypothetical example
[Music]
some hypothetical examples are silly i
think this is quite illustrative because
in almost all machine learning problems
most of the data is irrelevant it just
it sounds like
the intersection of a bunch of of things
that so one is
this notion of inverse reinforcement
learning or
imitation learning where you
sort of learn from expert demonstrations
right
the second one is sort of curriculum
learning where you assume that you have
an expert that can sort of guide you in
which
examples are the next best to learn and
then the the last one
is um reward shaping
so i i see that i see the machine
teaching angle
like that the framing of things i i
don't
see the novel like i don't see what
makes this
its own field i'm a member of this new
this team called project banzai and
we're part of the uh
research group that's taking machine
learning or machine teaching
out into to our customers in this
industrial
autonomy scenario okay there's this
amazing article by alex urpan called
deep reinforcement learning doesn't work
yet
i honestly recommend that anyone even
thinking about embarking on a deep
reinforcement learning project
should read this article it was written
in in 2018 but
it's almost 100 it basically is 100
relevant today
and i think this article gives a little
bit of insight into why
bonsai exists um
certainly when i worked at microsoft
there were loads of reinforcement
learning cowboys creating
reinforcement learning projects and they
were almost always
a complete waste of time and money and
they failed and the problem is
it's so easy to have a false sense of
security when it comes to reinforcement
learning even if you're an expert in
machine learning
it's an order of magnitude harder to do
deep reinforcement learning
and i don't think people realize just
how finicky and how complicated it is so
it starts off with a meme
whenever someone asks me if
reinforcement learning works i tell them
it doesn't and 70 percent of the time
i'm right
he says that deep reinforcement learning
is surrounded
by mountains and mountains of hype and
for good reasons
reinforcement learning is an incredibly
general paradigm
and in principle a robust and performant
reinforcement learning system
should be greater everything so merging
this paradigm with the empirical power
of deep learning
is an obvious fit deep reinforcement
learning is one of the closest things
which looks anything like agi
and that's the kind of dream that fuels
billions of dollars of funding
unfortunately it doesn't work yet he
believes that it can work
he says that there's lots of problems in
the way many of which feel fundamentally
difficult
and he said the beautiful demos of all
the learned agents
hide all of the blood sweat and tears
that go into creating them
it's really important that you uh that
you get that
so he says that many people get lured by
the recent exciting work
and they try deep reinforcement learning
for the first time and without fail they
underestimate the difficulty of deep
reinforcement learning
the toy problem is not as easy as it
looks and without fail
the field destroys them a few times
until they learn how to set realistic
expectations
i think this is a real concern if you
are
especially if you're outside of the tech
industry if you have an
internal team working on deep
reinforcement learning because they've
been excited about all of the hype and
so on
you should really take a look at that
because you're probably wasting your
time
this is one of the reasons why bonsai
has a very clear interface and a
consulting model
because i think there's a realization
that deep reinforcement learning is just
very error-prone very very difficult
and it's not really something you should
be embarking on on your own because
you'll probably fail now the main
problem deep reinforcement learning can
be
hideously sample inefficient remember
the deep q networks paper
that took something like 200 million
iterations to converge on those atari
games
and there was no generalization you had
to build a new model for every single
game
there was this rainbow dqn paper from
2017 which kind of
did an ablation study and kind of showed
the relative contributions to all the
different reinforcement learning
algorithms up to that time
and they exceeded human level
performance on over 40 of the 57 atari
games attempted
more recently with go explorer it's now
all of the games
on the y-axis here they've got a median
human normalized score
so it's computed by training 57 dqns for
each of the atari games and then
normalizing the score of each agent such
that the human performance is 100
and then plotting the median performance
against 57 games
so rainbow dqn passes the 100 threshold
at about 18 million frames
and that's about 83 hours of gameplay
experience that's actually significantly
more sample efficient than
what went before but it's still very
very sample inefficient when you take
into consideration that
a human can just start playing one of
those atari games within a few minutes
and be able to
be productive at it so the take-home
message is learning a policy will
usually take
more samples than you realize there's
quite a cool example here this is the
deepmind parkour paper from 2017
and they trained a policy using 64
workers for over 100 hours
the results are really cool so
essentially they had a kind of skeletal
system with
with joints and the reinforcement
learning policy was
controlling all of those joints and the
reward function basically was quite an
easy one
it didn't really have deception because
if if you see this particular search
environment there isn't deception in the
in the search space it's just
you're just kind of going from one side
of the map to the other side of the map
but in spite of that the solution was
very sample inefficient
so the author also points out that if
you just care about final performance
then many problems are better solved by
other methods
but there's an example here on the
majuco
robot demo using model predictive
control instead
and the results are pretty good and
using model predictive control they
could also
do planning against a world model or a
simulator as the author points out here
it's also possible to
easily outperform deep q networks just
using an off-the-shelf monte carlo tree
search
so in most cases just using a domain
specific method is actually better than
using deep reinforcement learning
so it says that the rule of thumb is
that domain specific methods work faster
and better than reinforcement learning
he said one of the reasons why he liked
alphago was it was one of the first
unambiguous wins for deep reinforcement
learning classic example here being
boston dynamics you might think that
they use reinforcement learning
no you'd be wrong they use time varying
lqr qp solvers and convex optimization
they don't use reinforcement
learning so reinforcement learning
assumes the existence of a reward
function
usually this is given or hand tuned or
kept fixed over the course of learning
and there are exceptions as alex points
out so when we're doing inverse
reinforcement learning or
imitation learning of course so he says
importantly for reinforcement learning
to do the right thing
your reward function must capture
exactly
what you want to do reinforcement
learning has this annoying tendency to
overfit your reward
leading to do things that you didn't
expect and this is why the atari is such
a nice benchmark right because it
it gives you the reward function the
reward function is the score
so not only is it easy because you get
to sample
loads and loads of frames from the game
the goal in every game is just to
maximize the score which makes it really
really easy you don't have to worry
about defining your reward
he also says this is the reason why
these majoko tasks are so
popular so when you start off in
reinforcement learning most of the
rewards are sparse which means
it's only at the end of the game that
you know whether you've won or not so
what do we do well we densify the
rewards so that every single step in the
game we have some indication if we're
doing better
and then we can monotonically optimize
on that reward
but then we introduce deception into the
problem so it's
not a panacea by any stretch of the
imagination alex says that shape rewards
can bias learning
it can lead to behaviors that don't
match what you want yeah and a great
example of this is the coast runners
seven game
and this is where the boat completely
forgot that the main objective of the
game is to go around the map
one of the intermediate kind of reward
shaping goals was to pick up these
bonuses along the way
and the boat is now just picking up the
bonuses the entire time and has
completely forgotten
that it should be going around the
entire map so alex says of course
reinforcement learning does weird things
when the reward is misspecified
he says that reinforcement learning
algorithms fall along a continuum
where they get to assume more or less
knowledge about the environment they're
in
the broadest category model 3
reinforcement learning is almost the
same as a black box optimization method
these methods are only allowed to assume
that they are in a markov decision
process
he gives another example there was a
paper from salesforce in 2017
and the goal was text summarization and
they just had to optimize on the rouge
score so of course reinforcement
learning gave the highest
rouge score with a you know 41.16
and this was the text that was created
it's fairly nonsensical of course so
lewis hamilton has full stop in 11 races
full stop full stop the race full stop
to lead 2 000 laps full stop full stop
in full stop full stop and
so you know it just goes to show that um
artificial intelligence is very
problematic right because you have to
design these benchmarks and these reward
functions and these metrics
and there are always shortcuts so the
problem becomes
stopping your reinforcement learning
model or machine learning model from
taking those shortcuts
there's another example here from popov
in 2017 so the lego stacking paper
one of the failure modes was at the
learn policy learned to tip the red
block over
instead of picking it up and alex says
here for reference uh here's one of the
reward functions from the lego stacking
paper
uh which is hilariously complicated he
said he didn't know how much time they
spent designing this reward but based on
the number of terms and the number of
different coefficients
he guessed a lot right so
even given a good reward local optima
can be hard to escape
so we've just spoken about reward
hacking in the previous section but also
there's this thing about deceptive
search problems and local optima
and alex points out he thinks this is to
do with the exploration exploitation
trade-off and i agree this is absolutely
about
we need to explore the search base
properly so that we don't get stuck in a
local optima
so this is an implementation of the
normalized advantage function on the
half cheater environment
and as you can see the cheater has now
learned to run upside down on its back
so this is equivalent remember the maze
example i showed you before this is like
getting stuck in a local optimum because
the search space is deceptive but alex
comments here from an outside
perspective this is really
really dumb but we can only say it's
done because we can see
the third person view we have a bunch of
pre-built knowledge that tells us
running on your feet is better it's all
about knowledge
deep rl is popular because it's the only
area in ml where
it's socially acceptable to train on the
test set
he says the upside of reinforcement
learning is that if you want to do well
in an environment
you're free to overfit like crazy the
downside is that if you want to
generalize to any other
environment you're probably going to do
poorly because you over fit so badly
right deep q networks can solve loads of
atari games but it does so by focusing
on learning a single goal
getting really good at one game the
final model won't generalize to any of
the other games because it hasn't been
trained that way
lanktot in 2017 at europe showed a
similar result
here are two agents playing laser tag
the agents are trained with multi-agent
reinforcement learning
to test generalization they run the
training with five random seeds
and here's a video of the agents that
have been trained against one another
so so far so good you can see that they
learn to move towards each other and
shoot each other
and they took one player from the
experiment they pitted it against player
two from another experiment
if the learned policy is generalized
then we should see similar behavior
only we don't this seems to be a running
theme in multi-agent reinforcement
learning says alex
when agents are trained against one
another a kind of co-evolution happens
the agents get really good at beating
each other but when they get deployed
against another unforeseen agent
performance drops the only difference
between these videos
is the random seed he goes on to say
even ignoring generalization issues the
final results can be unstable
and hard to reproduce almost every
machine learning algorithm has hyper
parameters
supervised learning is fairly stable
right because we have a fixed data set
ground truth targets if you change the
hyper parameters even a little bit
your performance probably won't change
that much so alex says that
currently deep reinforcement learning
isn't stable at all and it's hugely
annoying for researchers he said that he
started working at google brain and one
of the things he wanted to do was
implement the algorithm from the
normalized advantage function
paper he assumed that it would only take
him two to three weeks but it took him
about six weeks to reproduce the results
and thanks to several software bugs you
know the question is
why did it take him so long to do this
he says and by the way this is a guy
that was working a google brain you know
this is one of the smartest people
imaginable
imagine how long it would take you to do
it let's consider the simplest task in
the open ai gym the pendulum task
in this task there's a pendulum anchored
at a point with gravity acting on the
pendulum and the input status
three-dimensional
the action space is one-dimensional so
the amount of torque to apply
the goal is to balance the pendulum
perfectly straight up
so this is a really simple problem and
it's made even easier by a well-shaped
reward so reward is defined by the angle
of the pendulum
actions bringing the pendulum closer to
vertical
will not only give reward they will give
an increasing
reward and the reward landscape is
basically concave so it can't really get
any simpler than that
and he gives a video below demonstrating
the policy that he found well the
pendulum doesn't even stand up straight
but at least it seems to counteract the
gravity
the next thing is he kind of trained
this about 10 times and only 7 out of
the 10 runs worked so
three of the runs didn't even work there
was a 30 failure rate
do you count that as working or not he
gives an example here of another paper
from europe's in 2016 and they were
trying some different
reinforcement learning algorithms on a
problem and as you can see there's just
this incredible variability
right so he says there's lots of
variants and supervised learning too but
it's rarely this bad
he said that if my supervised learning
code failed to beat random chance 30
of the time he'd have super high
confidence that there'd be a bug in the
loading or the training
now this is really interesting he quotes
this picture from why is machine
learning hard
and the core thesis is that machine
learning adds more dimensions to your
space of failure cases
which exponentially increases the number
of ways you can fail
deep reinforcement learning adds a new
dimension
random chance the only way that you can
address random chance is by throwing
enough experiments at the problem to
drown out the noise
when your training algorithm is both
sample inefficient and unstable
it heavily slows down your rate of
productive research
maybe it only takes one million steps
but when you multiply that by five
random seeds
and then multiply that by hyper
parameter tuning you see an exploding
amount of compute to test hypotheses
effectively i think this diagram is
absolutely fascinating because
i often talk about why machine learning
is the high interest credit kind of
technical debts
and i say it's because it's not just
code we also have models and data but
it's so much more than that look at this
you know model issues and algorithm
correctness and implementation
correctness
every new dimension that you introduce
to the problem here you are blowing up
the
the space of possible failure modes this
is why it's so difficult to do machine
learning in the first place
and why you shouldn't do machine
learning unless you have to so um there
was a hacker news comment from andre
kapathi
back when he was open ai and he said if
it makes you feel any better i've been
doing this for a while now it took me at
least six weeks to get a from scratch
policy gradients implementation to work
fifty percent of the time on a bunch of
rl problems if it's taking andre capathy
nearly six weeks to get something
working how long do you think it's going
to take you to get something working
he says also what we know about a good
cnn design from supervised learning land
doesn't seem to apply to reinforcement
learning land
because you're mostly bottlenecked by
the credit assignment or supervision bit
rate
not by the lack of a powerful
representation he says that supervised
learning wants to work
even if you screw something up you
usually get something non-random back
reinforcement learning on the other hand
must be forced
to work if you screw something up or you
don't tune something well enough
you're exceedingly likely to get a
policy that is even worse
than random long story short your
failure is more likely due to the
difficulty of deep reinforcement
learning
and much less due to the difficulty of
designing neural networks
so i think that's really fascinating and
if andre capathy said that
then you know that we should be
listening so alex in the article goes on
to say that instability to random seed
is like a canary in the coal mine
if pure randomness is enough to lead to
this much variance between runs
just imagine how much an actual
difference in the code can make
there is a paper called deep
reinforcement learning that matters
in triple ai 2018 and it concluded
multiplying the reward function by a
constant
can cause significant differences in
performance so
complete lack of robustness five random
seeds
a common reporting metric may not be
enough to argue significant results
different implementations of the same
algorithm have different performance on
the same task
even when the same hyper parameters are
used he said that his theory is that
reinforcement learning is very sensitive
to both your initialization
and the dynamics of your training
process your data is always collected
online
and the only supervision you get is with
a single scaler for award
a policy that randomly stumbles onto
good training examples
will bootstrap itself much faster than a
policy that doesn't
a policy that fails to discover good
training examples in time will collapse
towards learning nothing at all
as it becomes more confident that any
deviation it tries
will fail so he goes on to say um what
about all of the great things deep
reinforcement learning has done for us
well he says that outside of the
successes reported by deepmind etcetera
it's quite hard to find cases where deep
reinforcement learning
has created any practical or real world
value he said he tried to think of real
world use cases
and it was surprisingly difficult he
said he expected to find something in
recommender systems but it was dominated
by contextual bandits and collaborative
filtering
i think this has probably changed a
little bit now i'm sure there are some
fairly good examples of deep
reinforcement learning being used out
there this is probably the only
part of the article that is dated but to
be honest not by a lot i don't think
there are many
examples out there of reinforcement
learning
[Music]
i've seen some marketing people online
say that prescriptive ai you know which
is when you actually make decisions and
act in an environment is true ai
and normal vanilla machine learning is
not true ai
and to be honest this really annoys me i
think they need to read francois relays
on the measure of intelligence
i mean first of all you have this thing
called the mccorduck effect which is
that every time we make a breakthrough
in artificial intelligence
there's always a chorus of people that
say oh that's not really intelligent
what's really fascinating is that chalet
in his paper
actually i'm amazed that google didn't
fire him for that paper because he was
certainly going against the grain but
he came up with a formalism of
intelligence which makes reinforcement
learning algorithms look really dumb
i'm not saying that chole is definitely
correct there are different schools of
thought for example
leg and hutter in their own conception
of universal intelligence they think of
intelligence as being
an agent being able to perform a variety
of tasks in different environments
francois charles has an anthropocentric
view of intelligence
and he thinks that intelligence
basically is kind of like
generalization ability and skill
acquisition normalized by
the amount of experience and the amount
of priors that you have
so you know it's said slightly
differently he thinks that intelligence
is
the efficiency at which you turn
experience
into generalizable programs he also
advocates for this kind of embodied
conception of intelligence
he thinks that intelligence emerges from
the interaction between
a brain a body and an environment
so a lot of the ideas here actually come
from francisco varela the
cyberneticist do you remember we were
talking to professor mark bishop a
couple of weeks ago and he also believes
in an embodied intelligence
so i suppose in that sense francois
chelay doesn't really think that any
brain can be intelligent you know
intelligence is actually an emergent
behavior
a brain must be embodied right so a
brain is in a body and the body
interacts with the environment
and intelligence is actually something
that emerges from that entire
process but it's still possible for the
brain to have an intelligence potential
which francois charlay thinks is a
function of its information acquisition
efficiency
and you know it must be dialed down by
any explicit knowledge or experience
that you give it by the way yannick and
i have made about six hours worth of
videos on
francois for layers on the measure of
intelligence paper so
i really recommend you check those out
and by the way francois chile might
possibly be coming on the podcast at
some point so
watch out for that but yeah i think it's
a little bit misguided this marketing
material saying that when you act in a
system it becomes more intelligent
to a certain extent that's true as we
know from some of the deepmind papers
that you can actually learn
causal factors when you interact with a
system but what is that system
that system is actually a simulator
which has been explicitly coded
so the reflexivity isn't really there
because the simulator will only give you
states that have been explicitly coded
and also it only interacts with the
system during train time
during test time the policy is
completely fixed
and remember intelligence is actually
embodied it's about
how brains and bodies interact with
their environment so
i think it's very very um strange to
refer to you know this kind of
prescriptive intelligence as being the
real intelligence
and by the way that slide came from
gartner so i mean that's i mean
i already think that anything in
powerpoint has zero credibility but if
it's got gartner written on it it's got
even less credibility
so i really think francois chelay is
onto something about
having the generalization having to
train the model
57 times for every single atari game
that doesn't really impress me
it'd be much better if you could train
the same model on the 57 games and be
able to generalize
between the games and then maybe what if
you didn't train on all 57 and then you
could zero shot
the same model on one of the other atari
games that would actually be a
demonstration of generalization
but what we know already is that the
models don't even generalize
inside one of the games they overfit
they learn weird patterns
and they have hardly any robustness so
i think there's a real kind of challenge
here around generalization
and this focus or this obsession with
kind of skill
or benchmark type performance i think is
getting us into a real cul-de-sac in
artificial intelligence
but anyway coming back to bonsai as we
said before if
intelligence is the skill acquisition
efficiency and generalization divided by
prize and experience well
the thing is we don't need intelligence
remember intelligence is about learning
the structure of the maze
but we already know the structure of the
maze for many industrial control
problems and automation problems
so why don't we imbue that knowledge
into the system as far as bonsai is
concerned
intelligence is irrelevant right what we
need to do is solve some physical
processes and some industrial control
problems
and we already know what the structure
of the maze is we can actually create
this hybrid predictive architecture
and some of it will be learned and some
of it will be an expert system
and if we don't care about intelligence
if we just care about being able to
perform one task well
then it's a function of knowledge
experience and information acquisition
so we can minimize the effect of
information acquisition which is the
part that we have to learn
by imbuing the system with experience
and knowledge so essentially if we
formalize that as an interactive process
we are cheating and we can actually do
what we want to do much better
so yeah the thing i love about chalet is
he just drops truth bombs like it's
going out of fashion
he said recently that as far as current
machine learning is concerned
generalization originates from the
ability to learn the latent manifold
on which the training data lies i.e
the ability to interpolate between
training samples
local generalization by definition he
says
as such attempting to study
generalization
by fitting models to random data is a
category error since
such data offers no possibility of
generalization
to understand generalization you must
look at the relationship between models
and natural data manifolds he says that
in the future
ai will be capable of extrapolation not
just interpolation
broad generalization and further general
intelligence
this is an endeavor entirely orthogonal
to the kind of interpolation and curve
fitting
that we're seeing now with deep learning
he says that it will be achieved through
an entirely different set of techniques
he finishes by saying of course
interpolation and pattern recognition
are nevertheless
a fundamental component of intelligence
just not the most powerful thing
being able to do it well by refining
deep learning is still immensely
valuable
now let's talk about machine teaching
now bonsai
they use this term machine teaching a
lot and it was something that i
initially had an allergic reaction to
and the reason for that is if you go on
to google and you search for machine
teaching
you get something completely different
machine teaching
academically is all about well what if i
already knew what the optimal model was
to do something
so i already had the parameters for the
model what is the most
salient and parsimonious data set i
could give to that model
so that when we train again from scratch
we obtain the same parameters
and the idea of the best uh training set
here
is we we can use this concept called the
teaching dimension to reason about this
and it's very similar i mean it's
similar to complexity theory basically
and machine teaching is harder than
machine learning now remember this is an
academic
exercise because if we already know what
the best model is
then we don't need to do machine
learning right so this is a fairly
pointless exercise
and the other thing is that machine
teaching in this context is np
hard it's very very difficult to solve
this optimization problem to find the
minimum data set
to obtain the same model parameters that
we had before
but what this means though is in the
case of an svm
the minimum amount of data to learn the
optimal
svm hyperplane that we already found in
this case would just be two examples i
mean later on yannick said that it might
be three examples and we'll
we'll touch on that as as we come to it
it's a similar thing if we want to
estimate a gaussian density
we only need to have three examples in
order to best estimate the gaussian
density but if we just generalize a
little bit
the concept with machine teaching is
we're still doing machine learning
but machine learning is just hideously
inefficient right just think about the
infinity of data there is surrounding
this gaussian density
and almost all of it is irrelevant
almost all of the data here in the svm
is irrelevant well it is relevant
because the training algorithm still
looks at it
but with a little bit of domain
knowledge we can actually discard almost
all of that data
so one of the ways that we can overcome
the sample efficiency problem in machine
learning
is by being a little bit smarter about
how we hold the hand of the machine
learning algorithm during training
now there was a guy at microsoft called
patrice simhat
and he popularized this concept of
machine teaching and even published a
paper on it
and he had a slightly different vision
on this and to be honest when i
read his paper for the first time i had
the same feeling
i think we both discussed that there was
kind of a alarm going off a
little bit
uh but digging into it like i've become
a little bit more convinced of it
although i still find a little bit
difficult to kind of get a grasp on it
right it's also because
we are microsoft and we've thrown a
beautiful marketing sauce over it
so his idea of machine teaching is that
we should take the machine learning
process and we should make it an
interactive process with
domain experts if you like to build the
model and
almost from a kind of software
engineering point of view we should
formalize how all of those steps work
from the end to end
so i suppose his idea of machine
teaching was instead of focusing on the
ml
algorithm knowledge take a step back and
just focus on what you want to teach
and how best to teach it traditional
machine learning is about extracting
knowledge from data
what we're doing is different machine
teaching is about extracting knowledge
from the human teacher
that's used to train a machine learning
model i'm going to introduce you to
building both a classification
and extraction model in pickle and i'll
show you how powerful decomposing a
problem and combining models can be
the second thing a teacher does is look
for examples and labels them
i've searched for a recipe that we can
label as positive
yellow highlights are for my search term
and blue highlights are for words that
are contained in my explanations
we can see that our current in progress
model does not think this is a recipe
the blue highlights show where my model
is predicting that there are ingredients
my bottle's getting lots of the
ingredients right but not all of them
so i would continue to correct the areas
by creating more explanation
and labeling more ingredient examples
like this
to increase the accuracy my extractor
model isn't perfect but let's see what
happens when we use it as an input for
our classifier
i will turn on the ingredient extractor
and the model will automatically retrain
with this new feature
now you can see that my model is
predicting perfectly for the examples
i've labeled
breaking the concept down and creating
that extractor was in a very effective
way for me to improve my classifier
what i've just showed you represents
about a day's worth of work for one
person
starting with no labels and requires no
deep ml knowledge
now i was initially quite allergic to
this because i thought well
remember machine learning is not a blank
slate right every single machine
learning model has
inductive priors even the hierarchical
organization of concepts in a deep
neural network you know they're
entangled together
that's an inductive prior there's a fine
balance between
adding domain knowledge and bias into
the model and removing the space of
possibilities where we can
but also expanding the possibilities
elsewhere
when people talk about machine teaching
i think they don't realize that almost
all of the process of machine learning
is machine teaching
right because when you select your data
when you do your featurization when you
select your loss function when you do
your
hyper parameter optimization absolutely
everything is machine teaching
all you're doing is you're imbuing
domain knowledge into the system
and you're helping your machine learning
model work better for this particular
domain
there are no predictions without
assumptions there is this bias variance
trade-off the whole point of that is you
imbue domain knowledge into your model
so that
where you can you can reduce the space
of possibilities
so that you can reduce your dependency
on data and you can improve
the generalization of your model so in
short
patrice simhard uses machine teaching to
formalize the process of creating data
models and objectives to make the whole
process
more kind of closely resemble software
engineering
right the interesting thing is that the
end user can also participate in this
process
and more of the process is externalized
replicable
reproducible scalable and formalized i
think that that was his vision with
machine teaching
now when we move back to bonsai they
also use the term machine teaching and i
think they use it in a slightly looser
way
and this was something that i got caught
up on at the beginning but
they use machine teaching as part of the
interface the design interface of bonsai
and it means that you can create these
hybrid predictive architectures
and without needing to know anything
about reinforcement learning
you can create these stepping stones or
building blocks you can create
curriculums you can define
self-play scenarios you can define
imitation learning and reward
densification
because remember the main challenges
with reinforcement learning are
the sparse rewards and the deceptive
search bases and the sample efficiency
problem
and all of these things can be largely
mitigated by
creating this kind of knowledge and
imbuing into the system
and they've created a domain-specific
language and a very
clear interface to abstract away the
complexity of doing that
this is for me at least kind of what for
example deep learning is it's just you
throw everything in there in the big
black box and
it will try out every possible
every possibility you can find and
eventually it will find a path
and it can be super useful if you had
really truly have no clue
on where the right solution or the right
answer lies but in this case like
we should be able to give it some
guidance and i think here it's a really
interesting
collaboration between machine teaching
and machine learning so to say
to see how we can train this ball and
train this machine most efficiently
i find it very interesting that if we're
placing all this emphasis on the
teachers
what about the ethical side of it
because we're all humans all humans have
bias and if we're placing this much
trust in
humans like how are we dealing with the
bias getting into the machine
and i think that's something that so far
at least in the papers i've read and the
research that i've done in two machine
teaching
hasn't been highlighted that much but i
do think it's something very important
we should discuss as well
software is the most malleable medium
there is
with careful design you can create
abstractions with
layers upon layers of capabilities that
allow a creator to
create any kind of an autonomous system
today if you look at how early
autonomous systems are being attempted
they are super complex software stacks
typically siloed built by a super team
of experts
building a highly fragile and bespoke
system we know from experience
that salute systems constrain innovation
they are expensive in time and effort
and they don't produce
building blocks that can be reused
focusing on machine teaching
we are creating tools to capture human
taught expertise
and to apply to machines what if your
waste management company
could program its machines to separate
the garbage
from the recycling so that you didn't
have to
they won't need a phd in ai or data
science to do this
so anyway i hope this introduction has
given you a bit of a flavor for how
hacky and unpredictable reinforcement
learning is so i must admit
when i first started playing with bonsai
i almost had an allergic reaction
because i thought well i'm an expert
machine learning person
it's really kind of annoying that
they've abstracted away all of the
information behind an interface
is this a good thing to do are they
abstracting away too much information
it's very very similar to i don't know
if any of you remember
zamel which was the xml language to kind
of bridge the gap conceptually it
created an interface between designers
and developers
that were working on silverlight and
windows presentation foundation
and basically it was an interface right
bonsai does a similar thing it provides
an interface for a consulting
arrangement with microsoft
where the focus is on capturing domain
expertise
and abstracting away most of the
complexity of deep reinforcement
learning
the beauty of this interface is that
they can hide away all of the technical
information
and they can innovate behind the
interface so the interface for any
innovative company should be simple
accurate and well defined and once the
interface has been designed
it gives bonsai the ability to iterate
quickly
frequently and efficiently so just look
at uber for example right they have a
really simple interface which is
um i want to go from a to b and
behind that interface they can optimize
the driver selection algorithm or the
incentivization scheme or how they pay
the drivers or the driver hailing
experience
and this might actually be quite
innovative for bonsai because in the
future
they could add all sorts of things
behind the interface they could add
planning
or model based reinforcement learning
and we wouldn't even know about it
they could even add some of the more
recent innovations in reinforcement
learning like the go
explore paper which was just released
recently with you know cloon and stanley
etau
and that was dealing with detachment and
derailment in search problems so without
going into too much detail it was
if we find an interesting place in in
the search space
why don't we go back to that place and
explore from there
and that only really works when you have
a deterministic training environment
and of course then you need to robustify
your journey to get to that particular
space and you can explore from that
space
but you know then in test time it can be
a stochastic model
but that has now actually provided
state-of-the-art results on
all of the 57 atari games you know and
far exceeding human performance
even on montezuma's revenge so bonsai
could be kind of implementing all of
those new innovations
maybe they could even go a step further
and not just use reinforcement learning
algorithms but use
things like population methods or some
of the open-ended stuff that kenneth
stanley's been doing i think that's
really interesting as well
in summary bonsai have created an
information architecture or a rigid
interface
which creates an abstraction hiding away
all of the technical details of the
reinforcement learning
it externalizes and formalizes machine
teaching and how we create
domain knowledge and how we turn it into
a software engineering process
and how we run it in the cloud
this is scott stanfield from the
microsoft autonomous systems team
i've been really excited about taking
concepts around ai
and how do we reach out into the real
world
and make things better and improve
existing physical systems
let's see who can balance the ball the
longest okay this is a
relatively simple skill and by being a
human i've
gotten pretty good at this i'm using my
binocular vision to look at the distance
between the ball and the center
and then moving my hands up and down you
get the idea this is easy
it's actually quite challenging to do
this on a machine
and i think that's what makes this very
interesting there's also um a manual
setting
and this tim is using it right now and
this just shows you how difficult it is
even for humans to keep the ball
i mean on the plate let alone still in
the center
which i think makes it even more
impressive the fact that we can
start teaching this machine how to do it
by itself and learn by itself
how to how to take control of the plate
so cool
[Laughter]
hours and hours of fun so classic is a
pre-programmed mode
where it tries to keep the ball in the
center uh and keep it still
you see like even the movements make it
so much more subtle than
what you did tim yeah
i think the key thing is that i don't
know if you've heard the expression you
shouldn't make
knee-jerk reactions
it's an expression in the uk that you
know um if
if if someone you know punches you in
the stomach or something you
your your knee jerks out you make this
kind of
jerky reaction and that's the worst
thing you should do you should
you should regularize or smooth it's a
similar thing with driving you don't
yank the steering wheel to the right
hand side you feather it you kind of
make
small movements to because otherwise you
would crash
we use the word software engineering but
when i refer to engineers i'm
meaning now mechanical electrical
chemical engineers
they have a technique called a pid
controller it's a proportional
integral derivative controller with
three magic numbers that are used to
determine what gain is needed to reduce
that distance over time in order to get
this really amazing
balancing experience i this is it's
fascinating it
works with nearly any object that's
similar to the color and it can pick up
this obloid egg shape pid controllers
are
really robust and it's a good thing
they're robust they're using about 97
of mechanical systems today but they're
not approachable for someone like me
and frankly for a lot of the people with
simulators trying to solve industrial
control problems
you can only go so far with the pid now
i have here
the one and only clear moab version to
show you what's inside before we go any
farther
there is a single camera a little
raspberry pi 4
right here connected to a custom power
distribution
with three servo arms and a fan and a
whole bunch of magnets and twisted wires
to pass
fcc certification so bonsai is quite
interesting it's kind of like a halfway
house between
an expert system and a black box neural
network you can create these brains and
you can compose together expert systems
and rules
and also learned concepts as they're
called
so a concept might be balancing a poll
on a moving cart
and you can compose this concept into a
curriculum of lessons
you can plug a simulator in and then the
curriculum can have goals which can be
to avoid things or drive things or
minimize or maximize
and and reach certain things so that's
the kind of
information architecture of bonsai and i
think it makes quite an interesting
interface actually because it abstracts
away a lot of the complexity
of reinforcement learning now in their
sales material they say that it works
for
dynamic highly variable systems and that
their brains can
adapt to a wide range of scenarios and
of course that works on the assumption
that you have a decent simulator for
those scenarios
it also says that it works when you have
competing optimization goals or
strategies
now remember the problem with deep
learning is that it always overfits and
it always takes shortcuts so
that assumes that you can actually
create a kind of
information architecture in your
training routine such that it actually
does what you want it to do
they also say that unknown starting or
system conditions are supported so
brains can learn to handle
unknown inputs or unknown changes to
system behavior
and again we we must remind ourselves
here that deep learning models
are interpolators they are not
extrapolators these models will not be
able to do anything useful outside of
the training range so going on the
assumption that you've explored this
state space during training or you have
some kind of an expert system which can
actually generalize to this unknown
input
then it will work so i put together a
kind of illustration here of the kind of
thing that you might want to do with
bonsai
now remember when deep learning came
around what was really cool about it was
that you could train these ubiquitous
predictive architectures end to end
you know it was just one big black box
and even though there were specialisms
in different parts of the neural network
you could do multiple tasks at once you
had this end-to-end architecture and
that was in stark contrast to
some of the kaggle competition winners
where they would glue together all of
these different expert systems and
ensembles and models and they would glue
the output of one model into another
model
and it made it quite complex to
understand so bonsai is somewhere in the
middle
for the first time they've created an
interface and they've created a
ubiquitous
end-to-end system for building hybrid
predictive and expert system
architectures
so think of it as a bit like a workflow
engine but what's interesting here is
that these models are being
co-trained which means they will have
quite an esoteric dependency on each
other so you can no longer really do
interpretability methods on these models
in isolation you have to start testing
the entire system
so the extent to which this actually
makes your models more understandable
i think is in question now you might be
asking yourself well
why are we decomposing a problem into a
confection
of expert system components and and deep
learning components
well i love this maze example this is an
example of a deceptive maze
and remember any ambitious search
problem has deception
and that means that you can't trust the
gradient of your objective
if you monotonically optimize on your
objective
you will reach a local minimum so here
for example if our objective
or reward function was the distance to
the target state
then we would get stuck in this local
minima very very quickly
so the interesting thing about most
industrial control scenarios is that we
have lots of expert
process engineers and they actually know
the structure of the maze
so we don't need to learn the structure
of the maze in fact
our system can be a little bit less
intelligent because we can imbue
domain knowledge into the system and
that's kind of what we're doing here we
are creating stepping stones or building
blocks around the maze
and then we can create a curriculum to
basically work through the maze
systematically because we already know
the structure of the maze
so what we have here is a very
interesting confection of
learned concepts and expert systems and
these stepping stones they could be
deep learning models deep reinforcement
learning models or expert systems
so i'm going to create a new brain a
control brain today and i
i always use the the date and a letter i
think we're on g as in golf
we we just have this workspace here on
the left hand side
we have a list of the brains or controls
that i've built earlier today
the default starting point for this
teaching parameters
here the language called inkling which
i'll go over and finally
the system on the right let me start the
training right now
this takes a few minutes so i've just
kicked off the training train it to do
what
let's go back and look at the teaching
protocol here and give myself a little
bit more space
and as i'm scrolling through here
there's a few constants that we have in
this language
we have the radius of the plate which is
22 centimeters the first thing that that
indicates that this is something a
little bit different we have this state
now remember earlier i said
i could look at the plate and the ball
and see where it is relative to the
center
of the x and y position i also can infer
the velocity from the simulator
now the simulator also exposes two
actions i can change the pitch
and the roll and this corresponds to me
moving the stick forward and backwards
or left and right
and we've normalized these numbers so
the the servo motors would normally be
between i think it's zero and 22 degrees
in this case we made it easy by going
between negative one and one so far we
just set up the stage
we have a simulation called moab
and it's tucked behind this page right
here and if i go down to the simulation
you're going to see this in a few
minutes but this is the total state that
it's exposing
now this is a simulator that we built in
typescript on the front end
and the back end is python now this is
the one of our two main simulators that
we use for teaching humans about
teaching machines and in this case it's
already deployed and i have a few
instances looks like 20
that are going to be running to in the
background to teach the system
the goal is taking language in terms
that are familiar to
a subject matter expert ranging from say
your chemical engineer
so we are training right now we just got
fired up
we have 20 sims connected in the
background running about
180 iterations per second now we're
trying to satisfy
our overall goal which is a combination
of the two sub goals
and if i scroll down we have this lovely
3d view
of the moab simulator the nice shiny
this is the special
metal edition i believe we can see this
one
this one instance of the 20 coming along
at different iterations per second
feeding
the brain on the back end and that brain
is learning
what is the back's best action to take
given a particular pair
of ball x and y positions should i roll
left
or roll and so i'm going to leave the
velocity out but you can see
this sim is humming along you we would
know this is really successful and it's
settled in
once these two lines converge to zero
but you can see
all these minute corrections that's
because this is an under actuated
control problem in fact it's part of an
undergraduate mechanical engineering
class
and to solve this with a pid it's a bit
of work now
i have a brain i created literally let's
see did this one just finish i did this
33 minutes ago wow we hit 100
so let me stop training this one what
does make me wonder though is
who is the target group for bonsai
because i think as you said i think it's
very readable code if you know
code and scene code before but if i
would show this to somebody who's not
who's never seen code or is not a
programmer
or who has not worked with it i can
imagine this is pretty
overwhelming and that's also why i was
asking i think the graph makes a lot of
sense to me
that's why i was wondering whether the
graph is
influencing the code or if the code is
influencing the graph
i think we should be clear here that
domain knowledge experts can also be
engineers right
if you're trying to make the perfect
cheeto there's going to be some kind of
cheetos engineer which know exactly how
much air needs to be in there and stuff
like that so
there's definitely a target group of
domain experts where this would make a
lot of sense
but i think for me what kind of the
power of the machine teaching concept is
to me
is how can we have domain experts which
are
not technical which are not programmers
how can we get their knowledge into
algorithms without
needing engineers or needing data
scientists
we're trying to bring that technology up
a level and allow
non-ai experts but really the people
running
the plants my cousin runs a bread plant
he makes bread
and it's an assembly line and i ask him
what does he try to do with it every day
what's the goal it's to
it's a balance between throughput and
efficiency every day this one is
incredibly robust
it has it's very eager it's like a
german shepherd ready to play fetch
and not only can it balance it pretty
aggressively
if i'm good i can get it to play catch
watch this
oh it stuck the landing oh man i should
have been on this camera
look at that so i have a special brain
here try to show you something that
would be very difficult to do with
classic engineer controls i have a
special plate that one of our engineers
journey drilled a hole into thank you
when there's an
obstacle in the plate it doesn't clearly
the classic mode doesn't know that
there's
anything here so if all of a sudden
you have this system in the real world
and something unusual has happened
you would have to go back and redesign
the system however we can just
add that to the scenario the inkling is
five lines longer
we've included a bit of code to tell it
where this obstacle is
in space and now when i put a ball in
here if i roll it just right
it's gonna do everything it can to avoid
this i can go around the loop here
and try to get it to touch that peg and
i can't quite get it
you might also ask yourself the question
well why do we need a simulator at all
well the reason for that is that if we
trained in the real world we could
damage the equipment it could take
unsafe actions
and just because of the prodigious
amount of training data that we need
we're going to be relying on simulators
for the foreseeable future
but luckily commercial simulators exist
for many kind of
industrial control problems i could
upload any existing sim that you might
have
so you can bring your own for sure you
name it tell it how many instances you
want as long as you're adhering to our
sdk
which is state what actions can you
perform
and what some other configuration
information and
for you because you haven't seen inkling
before was this what you expected of it
not really this this is very declarative
which means it's the what not the how
so this is this is just describing
this kind of state diagram over here or
this concept diagram
and it's not telling you anything about
how things work it's just telling you
about
how things are related and what is going
on
it's showing you a schematic
representation
of the kind of state space and what the
properties are and what the
valid ranges are so i suppose what
surprises me is that
i'm just thinking what is is this it can
i just
press the train button now and it will
just work well we can try and as if by
magic it just feels like this is too
easy
i think we should also ask ourselves
what would happen
if we would have to build this from
scratch and you know the inkling
language wouldn't be in there and we
would be the ones having to figure out
how to do this
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel and podcast
today i'm here with scott stanfield
scott say hello
hey good morning or good evening thanks
for having me
it's an absolute pleasure now scott you
work for microsoft don't you
yes what do you do at microsoft i am a
uh i'm a member of this new
this team called project bonsai and
we're part of the
research group that's taking machine
learning or machine teaching
out into to our customers in this
industrial
autonomy scenario so i i am on the
i run the advocacy team for project
banzai and i get to talk to customers
and engineers
about this new technique of using
autonomy
in places where we've automated
machinery to do things
okay that's really interesting though
let's start with machine teaching
because this is
this is the thing that really interests
me now i was on an internal conference
when i worked at
microsoft and there was a guy called
patrice simhart and he gave us a
demonstration all about machine teaching
and i must admit it was one of the
things that i thought was
extremely esoteric i didn't understand
what the hell it was
and i've done a little bit of reading
recently and i think i understand what
it is but i still don't completely
understand how it relates to bonsai so
my quick reading of what machine
teaching is as follows
machine learning algorithms what they
essentially do is you feed them data
and they are inductive algorithms which
means you give them examples of
something and they turn those examples
into rules
and most of the machine learning
algorithms are extremely
sample inefficient which means you need
to give them loads and loads of data and
most of the data you give them is kind
of redundant
it's actually possible to put a
controller on the top we'll call that a
machine teaching controller
it's i think it's supposed to be an
interactive process but
maybe it's a non-interactive process as
well and this controller can give the
most salient
data to the machine learning algorithm
such that it learns what you want it to
learn
quicker is that is that fair yeah
it is it is um in a way you're using
human experience to guide the priors
um if you were to teach well let me use
american metaphor
but teach because i don't know how you
would teach someone to ever hit
a ball and cricket so i'm going to use
an american baseball metaphor where you
put a ball
i had i had a have a son he grew up
playing baseball and if you watch
professional baseball
the ball is being thrown to the batter
up to 100 miles an hour so you don't
teach them
by giving them examples of major league
hitters
in a supervised learning way and say
just get up and do that i'm going to
give you a thousand examples
this is what success looks like instead
you build a lesson
you start small you teach them how to
hit a stationary ball first
then you would add to it you take the
ball off the tee and you underhand soft
toss it so they get a parabolic arc
and they're learning how to swing down
to it so you're building up skills now
there's a direct analog in how we would
teach machines
there's so much about machine learning
in our literature
um i started with simple perceptrons
with no background
like a one layer perceptron in the 80s
and then moved to
uh i tried support vector machines
that almost killed me and then i found
the beauty of gradient boosted trees but
all this is focused on the learner the
machine
learner now we're focused on the machine
teaching so it's bringing a certain
pedagogy
to this effort where we're focused on
taking a human expert that maybe have
30 years in the field to know how to
debug
part of an assembly process or like take
cheetos
so pepsico owns frito-lay and they make
cheetos in the united states which is
that little crunchy snack food
assume your readers know what this thing
is
there are so many variables that go into
the production of it that you need a
multi-decade tenured operator plant
operator
to know what to do when something quote
goes wrong
and it goes wrong can be subtle and it
could be like the puffs aren't popping
or the there's too much ambient humidity
if they're made into houston and it's
really warm and humid
maybe there's too much latent moisture
in the cornmeal batter mix
and so we have heuristics as humans to
make these small
small changes but if you can codify
in a very high level language called
inkling
the human best practices or the lesson
plan or the goals
you want a system to learn to reach then
that coupled with a simulation
allows us to teach machines to do what
we want
okay so just to unpack that a little bit
because this is really interesting so
that there is um
there's a concept in machine learning
called curriculum learning
it's a little bit different to what we
were saying before so it usually isn't
meant
to mean data it's meant to mean
objectives
an example of this is in reinforcement
learning you might need to have an agent
solve a maze
and the problem is all all search
problems have deception
and what that means is that your
objective if you follow it monotonically
you'll get it you'll get stuck in the
maze right because you'll be trying to
increase
your you know this this objective which
is the distance to the end of the maze
and
you'll get stuck and that's why there
are things like epsilon greedy and
there's a whole bunch of ways to get
around this problem but what you're
talking about is
sometimes if we know the structure of
the maze
we can do something called reward
shaping and that's where we can set
intermediate stepping stones
to guide to the agent around the maze
and but
it sounds like that's what you're
describing so you're saying we we
understand what the curriculum is in
advance
so let's let's help the machine learning
algorithm
find its way through the maze by giving
it those stepping stones
that's that's a that's a great way to
explain it um i have a visual here well
i have
project moab which is a ball balance
robot that we use to illustrate these
these principles i've got one too i have
several yes we need to go through
yours this is my frankenstein bot you
know i take it apart
i have an arm sticking out and a logic
analyzer because i'm currently
trying to rebuild the uh spy bus
interface
but this one is a little bit cleaner and
if i take if i take this off and for
your audience here
um the the conceit here is that that
while this is an easy task for a human
to balance a ball on a plate
it's a um it's a it's not average level
yeah i know right so i have some
experience right it's much
harder to to build a robot to do the
same
and mechanical engineers would recognize
this as a
ball on plate problem and it's something
that is
well known you can solve it with a pid
controller now we've shifted the problem
we shifted the problem to gains for the
the p term the you know the g we shifted
the problem to knowing the gains for the
integral the derivative and the
proportional term in both x and y axes
inverse kinematics blah blah blah um and
so we can do that with this and we we do
we have a classic controller mode for
pid
but we also have a mode where you have
no prior knowledge of how
this world works and you just train it
using a simulator
in azure and it just through through an
informed
trial and error it will figure out the
best policy to keep the ball balanced
now um we use that as a stepping stone
then to meet what a pid can do but go
beyond it
and so we're coming up with scenarios
like what if you have a laser pointer
and you shine it on the plate
not only can it balance if we can have
the ball follow the laser pointer
something you could not do readily with
classic controllers
where you can bring in sensors from the
outside
but going back to building up a lesson
plan i was literally doing this before
when we teach the system i tell it to
first drop the ball on the plate
randomly in the simulator
somewhere between the radius and 50 of
the radius not out here
start it like kind of close and then i
also say the initial velocity of the
ball
is relatively slow because later if i
wanted to solve
you know a fast-moving ball problem i
can build
i can build upon the knowledge it's it's
learned the policy it's learned
uh when the ball is moving more slowly
so i'll just pop this back on
let's introduce a couple of concepts so
reinforcement learning
because you said a controller right and
a controller is
it's something that takes action in an
environment at a certain point in time
right so
it's actually really really difficult
using code
because you were talking about you know
this pit controller if you were to write
code if you were to write some java
and tell it to move that plate right
as a function of time you probably
wouldn't do a very good job of it it's
very very difficult to write that kind
of code
right yes but what you can do is you can
write a physical simulation right so you
can do your
euler integration or rk-4 integration
and you can model all of your
your forces and so on and you can build
a simulator so you can say okay well
what would happen if i drop the ball in
from here and from here and from here
so what reinforcement learning does is
it it takes that simulator
and then you train with lots of
different episodes and then if you have
an
objective function so you say this is
what i want to happen
and then it will tell you what the what
the best next action is
at that point in time for you to meet
your objective
yes yes you know it's funny you you've
kind of touched we've touched on the
three common personas the three
different perspectives to look at this
one is
through the eyes of the the data
scientists and they'll tend to ask
is this using ppo or actor a3c um the
answer is yes
depending if it's a real valued output
or categorical output
an engineer might look at and say um can
it
use my matlab simulator i've done all
the inverse kinematics in simulink
or any logic and the answer is yes
a programmer might look at it like what
you said because i asked them how would
you do this
and they very quickly you start to start
to break it down to these discrete time
steps but knowing how to carry the
errors forward and minimize the
over time and as i am a programmer and i
never knew what a pid control loop was
and so there's lots of different way a
lot of different perspectives to
approach this but because
at the end of the day our source of data
is the real world and simulators we
gravitate towards industry specific
problems that have
a a base of simulations so
the biggest would be math math works
company with simulink
but there's it's a very long tale of
simulations there are very specific
industry simulation problems and if
there isn't a simulation built
we're looking at ways to derive uh
some of the physical properties of the
world from from analyzing the data
itself
so there's it's a big space but trying
to
trying to make something that that makes
sense and actually works is
it's difficult controlling physical
things because you have lag
if sensor lag you have noise you have
discontinuity like we're literally
debugging a problem right now where
i have infinite velocity because at some
point the ball it doesn't even see the
ball
and then i introduce the ball not
velocity acceleration so acceleration
for one tick
is just off the charts so we have to
throw filter that out
so we still you know it's it's a process
many systems that we're modeling have
very complex dynamics
and it's increasingly difficult to
describe that i mean it's easier to
write a simulator than a controller but
you know it that's accentuated when you
have a system of complex dynamics but
just to frame this a little bit though
we are talking about model 3
reinforcement learning so we're talking
about the space of problems where you
can
write a simulator i would imagine that
there will be a class of problems where
you can't write a simulator and the
other thing that comes to my mind is
um there are problems with with machine
learning
algorithms in general around robustness
and generalization
so yes it's entirely possible that the
system that you're modeling might be
non-stationary
and it might be quite chaotic and it
might mean that the the policy that we
have learned today
might not work tomorrow so i would
imagine there are industrial processes
that are quite
um regular and stationary which you
could
use uh this product for and maybe other
things that you couldn't use it for
yeah the i think the idea is um and
very different from the ongoing field
for
you know people look at come in from the
outside and say oh it's like a tesla you
know using the autopilot or
features and then you look in the world
of autonomy just in automobiles and how
sae has
like the goal of level five autonomy
we're not talking about that
we're talking about um more
controlled industrial solutions that
that
do need some uh respond to some
some unknown space so you get the
simulation close enough
in a hyper-dimensional sphere and you
get it close but the idea is that you in
the simulation you can kind of push the
boundaries like
having a coverage so the
the policy has been exposed to a broader
a broader world
of what the possible outcomes would be
like in our case we
you know we're only balancing ping pong
balls i don't really
i haven't pushed it to change the mass
of the ball it is a sphere and spheres
work differently from solid balls
um so the shell velocity calculations
are different we don't really care
so i haven't really pushed the
boundaries on the weight of the ball but
it does generalize like we've balanced a
hard-boiled egg on it
and and so there's some cases where the
physics will just work in other cases
where
okay now we want to train it for a
broader broader spectrum to have more
robustness
deep learning models are in the space of
curve fitting essentially so
if you have a problem where you can
interpolate between
two known points during training then
then it will extrapolate to a certain
extent but
if it's a problem where um the middle
point between two
examples shown during training it bears
no resemblance then
then we're a bit stuck i suppose what
we're getting to here is why use bonsai
and the reason for that is what we're
doing is we're formalizing a process
around how we train and how we use these
things to
overcome some of these landmines and to
overcome the sample efficiency problem
and
some of the challenges that people
traditionally have with reinforcement
learning
yes yes and i i think the
we're finding that um like the world of
simulation which is where our data comes
from
uh these systems we're bringing the isvs
the solution providers along with us to
help prepare their
simulation software to work in the cloud
as well so we can dockerize
the the application the executable
and we can work with the vendor to make
their software kind of ready to be run
in the cloud
it's it's not only a technical problem
but it's also a licensing problem
so you look at the way a lot of these
big heavy-duty scientific
simulation packages work they might be
licensed on a per seat
uh like for one user maybe one eight
core machine but
we can run a thousand simulations in the
cloud
and orchestrate the learnings between
all of them at the same time
and we can even spin them up in such a
way that
it will bring on more simulations if it
feels like it can keep up with the it
can have a dynamic load
a dynamic simulation load if you will
and i found that with with just with
moab mo it's a very simple
simulation um and we find we see that
the
the engine itself is uh responsible for
bringing them up
you know dynamically it's really cool
and as our software backing gets better
i find
it only needs just a handful of
simulators because it can run quickly
more more sample efficiency amazing
so so on on this um training process for
example because i've logged into bonsai
and had a play with it and it's great
fun of course there's a lot of
complexity there that's been abstracted
away because essentially it's a
it's a it's a sas almost where you can
just spin up
and and virtually all of the compute but
um you
i'm trying to understand exactly how
this machine teaching thing comes in
when you train these things what you're
doing is you have a simulator and you
run lots of different episodes and
you're
you're training an agent basically and
it's kind of um traversing or
taking trajectories through this
simulator and
right i thought maybe the machine
teaching part of it might be that
you're kind of um making this process a
little bit more interactive so
you're either imbuing uh ways of
making this more efficient or or maybe
you're exploring the state space
dynamically so you're sort of saying
okay well i understand what that part of
the state space is
i now need to like explore parts of the
state space that i haven't
been to already and coming up with ways
to kind of make that training process
more efficient
that's a that's a really good insight
let me give you by the way of
another example when we um when we were
developing the simulation for this
first we look one of the ways to
approach to we call it like
uh brain spotting like transforming with
brain spotting like is this
a is is this problem space something
that can be solved with machine teaching
so we have some heuristics in fact
our customers and our internal solution
excel
the people that do analysis go through
some internal training
to help decompose a problem but it works
something like this what is the
how do we infer the state of the system
at any given time so there's what do i
know about it
and then what actions can i inflict and
how fast should i make decisions
and what should i be driving towards do
i want to maximize a number
minimize some value drive towards
some goal but keep it within some
epsilon area in the case of the ball
and so we think of it as reward shaping
you have a terminal reward function
but we also have this higher level goal
satisfaction so you get
multiple goals that you're trying to
achieve in my case there's two
avoid falling off the plate and drive
the ball to the middle
and those are each defined with one line
of code
and then the outer bits that the machine
teacher do
like our simulation for this exposes a
lot of
pieces a lot of variables
that we run at say 30 hertz but i know
most about reading how other people have
solved this particular problem is all
you really care about
is the x and x dot property the position
of the ball and the velocity of the ball
so four numbers in this case in the x
and y position
and the velocity in both so there's four
inputs
and then the only thing that the brain
can do in this case
is pitch the joystick forward and back
or left and right
so i'm mapping four numbers into two
real valued numbers between negative one
and one
but so i as the teacher kind of know
this
like i like that's i want to glue these
things together and i'll know if it's
successful if the ball stays on the
plate
so i want to reward it for how long it
stays in the middle
and i could have also just as easily
bypass the inverse kinematics instead of
trying to
control the pitch and roll instead i
would say control the position of the
three motors
so i have a completely different
interface where
i know because i built this but the
servos go from 90
wait 155 degrees to 90. it's kind of a
weird
i should have normalized it from zero to
90 but
i know that's where all three go and
trying to convert a
human's joystick to three motors is a
kinematics problem
not easy by the way that's a great
example though because this is what
machine learning does for us
right so um that there is a functional
mapping
to go from the motors of those arms to
the pitch and the roll
and we could let the machine learning
algorithm learn that for us
and in fact it might not be as clean as
this as
it it's going to have some slop right
it's
it might not be the the perfect because
it's a fairly low dimensional space that
that's solved well by people that know
mechanical engineering it is a 13-page
research paper
i mean it's not trivial you know you
have to brush off your pd's and
or ods and i'm like okay this just
wasn't my
my bag i i appreciate it um
in fact it was an interview question for
one of the folks that are on my team
she's a mechanical engineer
in robotics and she actually improved
the paper
um but it's it's it's an example of even
a small
toy problem like this is
worthy of exploration in this space
and is a and can be approached by from a
machine learning hat
electrical engineering mechanical
engineering and computer science
and that really it's kind of it's the
form of mechatronics it's just now we
have this small kit for our customers
and partners
to dive into to start to explore the
space so
even though we focus on mechatronics
frankly the reason
i did this is because like chemical
engineering
in movement of fluids between tanks
using a pump
academically is interesting visually
it's not terribly interesting
like the two is a classic problem called
the two tank
or the four tank problem the two tank
problem you have two
two vertical cylinders of fluid you have
one pump that you fill the top one
that's draining at a consistent rate
into the bottom one and your goal is to
keep this level fluid
consistent actually it seems like kind
of a fun pub game
like you could put put a coin in and you
get to turn the pump and whoever
keeps the level they're the longest wins
i don't know maybe maybe we should make
this like something that you can play
with that build
when we all get back together definitely
um but that's a
real that's an analog of a real physical
problem um
that when you multiply this out by
multiple tanks multiple
it starts to get to be a very hairy
control problem
and that's where augmenting humans in
these decisions
can be really useful because i'm trying
to draw a contrast to
traditional reinforcement learning so
even with this project moab which is the
thing with the plate and the ping pong
ball
someone's written a simulator somewhere
and then yeah there's a kind of
interface
there's an interface language for
describing all of the physical
uh parameters of that simulation right
and and then
you can um build this model and and you
define the objectives
and and again this is this is quite
declarative so you could you said
yourself yes
um the ball needs to be as close to the
center as possible and it shouldn't fall
off
and that seems like a bit of a
divergence because in traditional
reinforcement learning you just have
one one value like a reward basically
and
you would have to come up with some
contrived combination of those
objectives
and you would have to learn some trade
off whereas what i'm seeing in bonsai is
that we're almost
em embracing the ambiguity to a certain
extent so saying look we've got
we've got this objective maybe i want to
maximize my throughput or something and
then i've got
i've got this thing down here i want to
maximize my uh my overall latency or
performance
and you kind of describe this in what
looks like a computational graph
so is that is that how you're imbuing
knowledge into the system is is that
what you mean by actually teaching
yes and i i think what it's doing is
starting to empower the engineers that
are making the simulations in the first
place
that would allow the data scientists and
engineers and classic
engineers that are that know how the
physical system work
to combine their knowledge to build a
system
and i i think it's um we're really just
at the beginning
just last monday we had a series of
announcements
one for bell flight and how we're
helping them do autonomous landings
and another piece on the the the
frito-lay cheetos example
and so we i can give you some links at
the end that you can throw in if people
want to go learn more i have a
an eight minute video start to finish of
how moab works all the source code for
this is available as a sample to
understand project bonsai
and so we have a lot of a lot of
resources coming i want more examples i
want
um it's it's it's so
interesting that this approach can be
used across so many different industries
it does again it's
complexity is always in the system like
you can't there's some law
of like entropy you can't minimize
complexity you can only shift it around
the complexity is already there in these
simulations that exist
already it's just an optimal policy
might not have been found yet so using
rl to find that
reinforcement learning itself is
necessary but not sufficient
we also need and we have the technology
to take the source of data the
simulation
and scale it pretty effortlessly in the
cloud and wrap the whole thing
and something that can be run in azure
and then finally
trying to put a a surface around it
using inkling to allow a subject matter
expert to define
what the system should do i think it's
those three things that make it all work
and come together
okay that makes sense because i was
looking for you to kind of
articulate what the the core proposition
was because um
i must admit that when i first looked at
bonsai i thought it was really cool
and i love the fact that it's a
completely democratized
user experience and i can go in there
and i could i can
learn the brain and it even shows me
look it's running on all these virtual
machines and
you can even visualize the runs as
they're happening and you can see the
ping pong ball going in and you can see
it
learning policy and you can see that the
graph of of the loss over time and how
good the policy is
you know that's really really cool but i
was also thinking in the back of my mind
that
there's still um in this particular case
you've done a lot for me so you've
already created this
this 3d model of the project moab and
you've created the simulator and you've
done a bunch of stuff for me
and how much harder would it have been
for me to kind of start from scratch
i suppose what i'm saying is that is
bonsai basically
a consulting play and i don't know
whether you want it to be a consulting
play or whether actually you're
bootstrapping an even more exciting
product in the future and it's just
going to take a while to get there
i think it's going to take a while to
get there this is this is a pretty long
play
um to answer the simulation question we
one of our engineers built this nice
looking javascript
you know typescript system to do the 3d
animation and
being that person's first simulation
took like two or three months
at the same time well a little bit later
but in parallel
we asked the folks at simulink to do the
same
they built in three days and they said
they would have gone faster but the
person
on their their team that knew that knew
simulink really well was not available
so all they needed was the motor specs
so they wanted the
the bill of materials they wanted the
cad diagram so they could infer the
linkages
and they were able to build a working
model in simulink
in a few days because that's what they
do right that's
there that's why there's a space of
simulations like we just
you know to make this approachable we
want to have the source code available
but really it's kind of an on-ramp it
exposes the developer community to the
need for simulation
but hopefully we're showing that the
simulation doesn't need to be perfect
it just needs to be close and we find
that when we over engineer
like there's no mechanics in here about
ball plate separation
we don't model that we assume it always
sticks to the plate and i think
we're not we're not accounting for any
kind of friction coefficient of friction
and
in the model we're not doing a fancy
like imagine
a billiards table when you hit the ball
underneath and you have a backwards
rolling until it changes forward
that you could do that we don't need to
it works fine it will balance it just
fine
so we've been talking the whole time
never actually did actually
show it balanced well we we've already
recorded some stuff showing it but feel
free to show it again
good because mine rarely is working
because i'm always testing it like this
is my
this is my this is my developer bot so
it's always in bad shape
yeah it's it's a it's a thing of beauty
so
i'm just i'm trying so this machine
teaching thing then the way i explained
at the beginning that makes perfect
sense so
give give the learner the most salient
information to to learn
what you want to learn as quickly as
possible but in i'm just trying to think
so
on this bonsai example with project moab
it
what exactly is the machine teaching
component if you if you think of machine
teaching as the whole exercise which is
starting with a known simulator exposing
the salient parts the sensors
actuators uh and then defining
the language like like right now the
you know our goal is to get the ball to
balance in the middle but i could just
as easily
um tell instead of in the middle trace a
circle
uh with a different kind of reward
function and and i mean you know i may
need to do reward or terminal
uh rewards it's called reward shaping
that you mentioned earlier i could do
that
um so that the teaching part
is the expression of some goal
or the breakdown of smaller lesson like
a lesson plan first learn this
and then with that brain learn another
you know extend the functionality so you
don't have to go relearn a task
so right now my lesson assumes a very s
like slow moving ball to give it kind of
a fighting chance
and then i can build on top of that
knowledge to introduce
a bigger variety of parameters and then
once i get the balance piece
together then i can control it from
another brain
to get to maybe navigate a path or
something
i see that that makes sense so the it
i suppose you're meaning machine
teaching as curriculum learning so
creating
um yes i'm not sure whether intermediate
objectives is the right thing or
additional objective is is it like
parallel objectives or is it
intermediate objectives
i think both i think both yeah so
intermediate objectives to
slowly build up the knowledge if we go
back to the baseball idea if i just
chuck the ball at you and you're trying
to hit it with a broomstick it's going
to be really difficult
so let's decompose that into two tasks
first learn how to hit a stationary ball
with a moving bat
and then once you which by the way is
very hard and very humbling if you watch
i'm sure there's youtube videos of big
guys you know
a weekend baseball or just walking up to
try to hit a ball that's an honest
stationary t
it's a humbling experience and because i
know i'm one of those
so first master that skill then you add
to it so that's a that's an incremental
approach
and then a parallel approach might be we
have this lunar lander example it's the
classic video game which you've probably
seen in open ai gym
where you have assignment you want to
land a little spacecraft on the moon
and you have a policy to move left and
right to stay within the flags
but you also have this parabolic
you know you have gravity to worry about
you want to start breaking at the bottom
and then you have to cut the engines out
so you could model that as three
different
brains that you could control all at
once um
or try to achieve them both at the same
time
the there's something called an acrobat
which is similar to the
inverted pendulum where if you balance
if you balance like a broom on the end
of your hand
that's an inverted pendulum but if you
start with it on a swing
and you want to swing it up there's an
energy minimization technique you can do
and once you have it upright then you
switch into a balancing mode
and we have a little robot it's just on
the other side of the room from a
company called kwanzer and they sell
this
beautiful little cube that spins it and
stands up
and you can control it with simulink you
can control it
using classical classic engineering one
of our engineers has taught it with open
ai gym
built in environment for it built a
simulation for it and then we can also
solve it with
bonsai as well and it's it's another
example
of of multiple ways to approach it and
what i found interesting
is that when we we told it to stand up
as quickly as possible
that the energy minimization swinging
back and forth only took three tries as
one
two up except at the top it
shook a little bit whereas the classic
pid approach
um took its time it took seven to eight
swings but when it
stood up it was perfect yeah and it
found it interesting because the
emergent behavior from the brain
we just told it stand up as quickly as
you can and so it
made it achieve that goal but then what
we would do through either reward
shaping or in this case with brains
have a new training okay now that you've
done this that's close good job
but i'm not exactly done now that you've
stood up
minimize this vibrational problem
you know if you're an engineer you know
you you need to tune
the i term to the i term or the d term
i forget in a pid controller i always
get them backwards
um so this would be
to answer your question yes both
parallel and
and uh additive i guess okay this makes
a lot of sense actually so
you're saying that you know to perform
um a particular task
you can decompose it into skills it's
very similar to the maze example i gave
before
so the overall task would be to get to
the end of the maze but um
mazes have deception which means you
need to have a curriculum of
intermediate skills or stepping stones
to get there
yeah it's a little bit like saying you
know if i want to have a computer vision
classifier that classifies me holding a
tennis ball
what i might do is create two
intermediate stepping stones so
a classifier that recognizes me a
classifier that recognizes a tennis ball
and then i might use those as two inputs
to another classifier that's going to
very quickly learn
you know tim with a tennis ball as
opposed to something else so
you're kind of creating a curriculum of
of tasks
but in bonsai you can represent
this curriculum declaratively it's how
you imbue the image into that that's
right
in the in the graph in the in the the
graph interface of course it's funny to
keep talking about the maze because i
it was just the anniversary or something
popped up recently about claude shannon
showing his little elect a little mouse
solving a maze
back in the what 50s late 50s
and i guess you know they had perfect
information um
it's it's fascinating that we're still
things that were discovered in the 50s
the uh what would he call the box the
skinner box bf skinner
created something called the skinner box
and later called it a teaching machine
and it was behavioral theory
what we now call positive reinforcement
and it really was around the whole idea
of putting a rat in a box and rewarding
it with a food pellet for doing the
right task
and so this this concept has been around
for
70 years now and we're still making
iterative approaches
i think the computational problem has
always been there
especially for large complex systems and
because there's so much human knowledge
locked up in these simulators with maybe
sub-optimal
control systems but the mechanical
mechanical physics are there
in order to respond to changing business
conditions
you can take that simulation and move it
um
we'll give you another example there's a
steel company
that a large industrial steel foundry
that makes galvanized steel and the way
you make galvanized steel
is through a process called hot dip
galvanization and you run
the the thin steel through a
hot bath of molten zinc and the zinc
you need to deposit around two to three
microns of zinc
to make it rust proof and if you don't
put enough on it
then it's going to rust and you've
completely ruined the product
if you put too much rust on it then
you've wasted zinc
sorry if you put a bunch of zinc on it
so it's a balance between
two two extremes like there's this is
happy number
but because they can't precisely control
it or they don't
they tend to put too much zinc on the
steel
and they realized with machine teaching
in a simulation
they can depending on the order that the
customer has
they can very finely tune the amount of
zinc that's deposited saving
a lot of money like we can't talk about
the numbers yet but it was astonishing
to me
not knowing and then i went and watched
about four hours of youtube video on
how seal works and galvanized steel and
hot zinc
uh bath dipping and so you've
so my youtube playlist is really strange
it's like you also might like this
and so all of a sudden i'm reading these
papers on on zinc and how it works with
steel
it's kind of cool no it makes perfect
sense good
because we're we're talking about you
know industrial process optimization and
and
at at scale and that volume even a
couple of percentage points could
translate to potentially millions of
dollars so
that there's a amount definitely that
there's a reason to do that yeah
because you know in the back of my mind
i'm thinking that you know there might
be a safety problem because
now we're trusting these black box
models and deep learning models they do
have a robustness problem which means
that if if you show them things they
weren't trained on they
they do weird stuff and and i think the
the extent to which that is a problem
depends on
the dynamics of the system but yeah sure
but at the end of the day you can't
argue with the fact that in
increasing the the efficiency of your
industrial process could save you
millions and millions of dollars
not to mention the fact that some of
these long-time operators that really
know the system might be retiring
or we need a way to codify their
knowledge to help
train the next generation as to what to
do and it doesn't have to be the thing
that
this brain that we talk about can i i
think the word autonomy i think we're
almost missing a term
and i think patricia mart was onto
something and we talk about it but
it's it's really it's guiding human
behavior guiding human decisions that
can be informed by
the computers trial and error experience
and so
in situations where you have to have a
high frequency response maybe we do
let the com you know it i can't
generalize because it's always going to
be a very specific case
as to how much of this is advisory
control
versus outright autonomy um
you know just like landing a plane with
autopilot you know the pilot saws their
hands on the stick
so at any given time can pull it away
but um
i think through training and simulation
for both human and machine
that's how we get to get to this process
and uh
just to have another tool in the bag is
is fascinating and and we're gonna have
more and more
uh case studies every six months or so
you know as we as we have new
success with our customers and can talk
about it we'll inspire
future engineers and data scientists
like yourself to maybe take another look
at this and see if it's something
applicable to their space yeah no i i
think it's a really exciting product and
at the end of the day there are so many
exciting ideas around machine learning
i'm interested in open-endedness for
example we spoke to kenneth stanley the
other week and
imagine just building um a sas product
that would you know that would abstract
it sufficiently
so that people can use this paradigm of
of machine learning
um but one thing i'll say is that i
think um
this style of um machine learning works
really well so this curriculum learning
works really well
when you know what the intermediate
stepping stones are that there are
problems
for example how do we solve agi you know
there are ambitious problems
where we don't know what the
intermediate stepping stones are but
we're on this interesting continuum
where you know we had expert systems in
the 1980s and that this was a world
where we
we knew we knew what the rules were and
we thought that if we could just you
know
codify everything and build programs
then we would be able to solve ai and
build any system we want but
you know those systems were actually
really brittle so then we did the
opposite end of the spectrum and we had
machine learning which you know we
thought we could be entirely data driven
and just trust the algorithms to do
everything
that didn't work very well either and
now we're in the middle
we have the perfect combination of some
learning where we can have learning but
also we imbue a lot of knowledge into
these systems as well
right that's a really good that's a good
take on this also we don't have to wait
like we don't have to wait for agi
we don't have to like these are systems
you know we have customers that are
putting it in pilot plants right now
and um you know using it as a means to
get their staff trained up and they work
with uh
either our partners or our members of
the project bonsai team
and we have we have phd consultants
in different backgrounds uh from
material science to
chemical engineering mechanical
electrical or earth
geophysical sciences that are
using on staff that are are working with
our customers
and really trying to find some of the
patterns that we can put into practice
into the software
and so i think you're going to see more
we have a lot more coming it this is a
very challenging space
and i think the relationship with the
simulation vendors
and also helping people that don't have
a simulation at all find a way to
it's just it doesn't have to be a
blocker
well scott stanfield thank you very much
for joining us this evening absolute
pleasure
yeah thanks for having me this is great
okay we're all here together kilter meet
meg
hello meg doctor hello
thank you so the first thing i want to
show you guys
is this orange ball what do you think
this
is your lunch
wow isn't that amazing
so this thing has got a manual mode
right
i'm going to put it in manual mode let's
see if my policy is as good as the one
built into the brain
there's a little joystick on the front
of it
some reason i can't do it
no it's too difficult you got to relax
man
relax you're too uh too stressed there
you go
gotta go with the flow get in your zen
space
then you can do it it's a bit unfair
though right
like if you if you took a plate and
tried to balance the ball you could
you could do it yeah in fact you could
balance it precisely in the center and
it would barely move
maybe it just has really bad
coordination guys you don't know
well he was he he did play a lot of
squash
so
[Music]
well that's not fair because the plate
has a lip that's helping it out
but i think this is this is kind of like
we can all agree it's
it's a hard machine learning problem
well no
no no i mean i mean it depends on
it is a easy machine learning problem if
you just
write the controller like you can reduce
the machine learning component to simply
recognizing orange pixels
right and once you recognize the orange
pixel you can just
in like build a classic controller for
keeping the ball in the middle it i
guess the
the question is is this policy a learned
policy
or is the machine learning simply
reduced to recognizing where
the ball is it's a it's a learned policy
and
okay that's where this machine teaching
thing comes into it so
first of all the interesting thing with
model 3 reinforcement learning
is that you can explicitly code the
simulator
and then you have some kind of training
protocol where you have
episodes with a certain number of
iterations inside the simulator
and usually there is some kind of um
starting state
which you just randomly initialize and
you set some parameter boundaries and
you
randomly or uniformly sample from uh
from that state space you run the
simulation and you see what happens
and then you optimize against some
reward function
yeah so can we back up and and define
what we mean by
model free model three means that
you um you have a simulator of the world
which is explicitly programmed
and because so that's that's a model
yeah because in reinforcement learning
you can have many different
architectures
and one architecture is you can have a
further level of
abstraction where you actually have a
model of the world as well
well the simulator is a model of the
world well the simulator uh oh
like just for our in the rl perspective
whether or not you have a simulator
has nothing to do with whether or not
it's model free or model based rl so the
specification
is is actually just uh in as tim says in
model based rl
you do have an internal model of the
world
um that is not learned that is actually
programmed hard coded in some way so
chess you can you can have like an
internal simulator
right in the rl algorithm and then you
can so they're just dividing yeah
you can do model based with a learned
model and so on model free url
is simply when in its most basic form
it's either
q learning or policy gradient where
you just input your current state into
some black box
and it outputs a thing to do
so it has it has no it has no explicit
notion of how the world works it simply
knows that if i'm in this state and i do
action 5
i get a i get a nice reward
that's that's model free and you usually
pair it yeah with like a simulator so
you can get lots of data
but you could technically do this in the
real world
all right and the thing that it's
learning i'm assuming is a deep neural
network is that right
yeah though i guess here probably a
linear function would do
uh given the given the right input um
input signals well in the context of
bonsai
how do i specify the parameter space
that i'm learning
is it whatever i want how does that get
specified so when you did the training
for this ball
what what did you give it to learn a
neural network
you know set of uh linear functions
or second order functions or what i
can't tell if you're asking me a trick
question on purpose but
no that all of that is abstracted away
so you you just define
the interface for the simulator so
what what's the simulator expecting and
then you define a kind of state graph
where you say these are the inputs and
these are the outputs
and then it will magically do everything
for you
yeah but i i want to know what the magic
is because there is no magic
so what is it magic learning dna if you
want to know what the magic is i think
bonsai is not for you
oh i see so they they keep that secret
so it's some so so inside that black box
for all we know
it has models exactly and i don't know
whether they are
doing some kind of auto ml in the
background maybe they
use different algorithms i don't know
okay so it is so that's all but this is
something that tim and me have been
discussing as well because i i think
that
if we're talking about project bonsai
all of us are probably not the target
group for this
because we want to know what's happen
what the magic is and we want to know
what's happening in the black box
i think the idea of machine teaching is
is that you can have these
domain experts which are not necessarily
engineers or technical and they can
provide input to an algorithm bonsai is
also not catering to that target group
because
they are using their own code and you
definitely need to have some kind of
knowledge of what it does
um so that was actually discussion me
and tim were having is for voices
i can tell you the target group because
i i did have this this conversation with
them and i'm pretty sure
it's fine for me to to talk about this
which is
the target group are enterprises that
have
very uh difficult and valuable
problems that they need to solve so for
example imagine
i'm just going to completely make
something up here don't don't but but
it'll make the point
imagine i have a nuclear reactor and i'm
trying to
come up with a system that can control
it in a better way more efficiently
more safely something like that so
obviously a problem that you're willing
to invest
quite a lot of money in has a lot of you
know risk associated with it
so the bonsai team will then enter into
an engagement where they work
with your data scientists and domain
experts to
to develop a
a an end product based on bonsai that
will achieve that
that kpi so they're looking for very
difficult
meaty um you know industrial problems to
solve
and then they're trying to be kind of
the bridge between that data science
scientist and the domain expert
or yep yeah so well they're trying to be
the bridge between the customers
domain expertise and the and the bonsai
engine or system and i guess also you
know bringing
bringing to the table expertise and
machine teaching
so that they know how to um
[Music]
carve up the data space such that
they can employ machine teaching these
are and these are long engagements too
like it's it's like let's work together
for months
yeah because this is my my follow-up
question because um
does that mean that bonsai can do this
faster or better or
compared to what a data scientist could
do or what is kind of the added
value proposition of bonsai here yeah i
think it's data scientists
obviously kind of have to wear many hats
right i mean there's there's a lot of
algorithms to learn
whereas bonsai or data science
who are experts in in this narrow domain
of machine teaching and and maybe i'm
not going to use the proper words here
but this reinforcement learning machine
teaching and so they have a very deep
expertise in that so the value that they
bring
is okay yes you have general data
scientists who understand
a lot of the observations and have
domain expertise but they
aren't necessarily experts in employing
machine teaching we can we can bridge
that gap we can translate your
your knowledge that you have into this
framework and i guess the value
proposition is that
this framework of machine teaching plus
reinforcement learning
can solve problems that other methods
either haven't been able to solve yet or
or can solve them
you know better in some way
yeah what i don't get in this is
what's the little robot doing like if if
you go into
into a month-long collaboration with
some
some company surely you're not gonna
plug some automl
in in at the end right like surely the
the hurdle
is not the whatever this programming
language where you define these
interfaces in some way like that's
surely not like like i can do that in a
day
right it's if i have a month-long
engagement
those are not that's not where the where
the time goes
so i'm wondering how does this all
connect to this
ball balancy thing i think the key
differentiator
here is the formalization of
how you train the machine learning model
which is what machine teaching is
so most of these folks are not
particularly interested in which
particular algorithm
is used and that goes to show because in
bonsai they don't even tell you
which algorithm is used the whole point
of this is that
the biggest problem is what's called ml
litter
which is or technical debt because of
the entire machine learning process is
completely backwards
in litter glitter is that what we
figured yeah well
exactly i thought the else already
stands for litter
it does yeah but um megan and i were
talking about this earlier but at the
moment
it's a horrible process you have to go
and get a whole bunch of data you ex
you give explicit instructions for
labelers this is how you label it
i then go and train a machine learning
model on it it's a complete black box
when my machine learning team get a new
job at google i've lost
all of the ability to reproduce the
model i don't understand how they
created it
i've got no idea how this thing is built
all of the machine learning process is
externalized
around the software engineering process
it's not integrated so machine teaching
is kind of
modularizing and kind of transforming
the machine learning process itself
into something that resembles software
engineering what's the best way to
it's just a control algorithm for
formalizing the machine learning process
this
this has been instructed so in an svm we
have a training set with n
items and it's euclidean data points
and and we have tuples so we have
signals and labels and the labels are
binary
so steve is the learner and steve wants
to learn an optimal separating
hyperplane which is just this w
vector which is a euclidean vector and
and that's what the algorithm does now
what we do in machine learning is we are
kind of
uneconomical what we do is we just throw
all the data we've got at the algorithm
and then the machine learning algorithm
will inefficiently
use that data and learn this hyperplane
now why don't we ask the question what
if we want it to be super efficient
what is the minimum amount of data that
we could give this svm
to get it to learn the optimal
separating hyperplane well it turns out
we only need two examples
so machine teaching is all about finding
the minimum
or optimal data set to help the machine
learner learn as efficiently as possible
i guess you i think you need three for
an svm
i guess that well the implicitly the
zero point here is a data point
yeah like if if you usually usually have
your uh
your bias so you need another data point
but this is
i mean it's it's a bit yeah it's a bit
so in this case what you want to do is
you don't want to learn you want to
transmit the solution
right right so there is someone oracle
already knows the solution because
in order for that person to figure out
which two or
three data points to give to you they
have already had
to solve the svm that's no
that's what i was thinking too it's it's
as it's as if somebody said
yeah you know you're doing these old
school linear fits and you're throwing
in the data and you're calculating all
these like
error squares and everything what if i
could just come give you two numbers
a slope and an intercept and you could
get the solution from this
is a hypothetical example is that
exactly
that i get it but some hypothetical
examples are silly no no no no i i i
think it serves the purpose quite well
so
we'll hear you out you give one more
illustrative example so i want to
estimate a gaussian density in two
dimensions
okay so you know i've got a whole bunch
of um euclidean vectors again
and so it looks something like this
i i want to learn this optimal gaussian
density
what's the minimum number of examples i
need turns out
it's three right it's the number of
dimensions plus one
um so again it kind of serves the
purpose because
what fascinates me about this is like
let me come back to the svm
imagine if i had loads of extraneous red
examples here and loads of extraneous
blue examples here
the support vector machine algorithm
would ignore them because they're not
support vectors they don't prop up the
hyperplane
and i think this is quite illustrative
because in almost all machine learning
problems
most of the data is irrelevant and it's
not done
it's not that the algorithm would ignore
it it's that the solution would ignore
it
the algorithm would very much pay
attention to it
right well yes
okay it depends on what you call the
algorithm but well so
in the case of the spm as you say the
decision function itself is only propped
up by the support vectors
but yes the algorithm in the dual
formulation still works on this inner
product matrix of all of the different
examples so computationally you need to
consider
all of the examples but that's hideously
inefficient
because i guess what i'm saying is is
you can discard
let's say 90 of those examples and the
decision plane would be exactly the same
okay but you you can't discard those
without looking at them
because if i change any one of those
data points then they may
now become one of the controls this is
when it gets interesting because yes you
can
because if you're a teacher so so let me
maybe i can frame this in a way that
like is not so uh like architecture
kind of kind of driven right which is
sticking with the svm example
okay uh the svm algorithm you know has a
certain complexity and it's been ages
since i worked with
svm so i don't know what it is you know
it takes a certain amount of
cpu to look at every other data point or
to look at every data point right
now somebody comes along and says okay
you know the thing is i have a different
algorithm that uh that's much more
efficient to run and you can do a first
pass
and chuck out 95 of the data because we
can ensure with you know
very high asymptotic bounds or something
that the five percent that are left
that the control points are somewhere in
there and then you can just run your svm
on that much smaller data set
right that's kind of what we're talking
about here like the teacher has this
sort of oracle algorithm that we assume
is more efficient than just the
svm algorithm or there's no point in
running it in the first place
and that it can run to screen our data
down to a smaller subset and then we can
run the more expensive algorithm like on
that
is that the kind of but i think you're
framing it in in in a way which i don't
like
i'm free i'm framing in a way that
people thought about 40 years ago that's
probably why you don't like it
right it's probably why a lot of people
won't like it especially uh
fanboys of machine teaching okay look at
this look at this so
the main problem in reinforcement
learning is the sample efficiency
problem right
if by default we learn you know um
deepmind brought out this deep q
networks and
they had superhuman performance on 7 out
of 26 atari games
the only problem was it was hideously
inefficient they had to
run millions and millions of training
iterations
to find the optimal policy and this is a
simple case where a little bit of domain
knowledge can
ridiculously cut down the amount of
training you need to do
all we need to do as a domain expert is
say look there are some ladders here
i strongly advise that you go and walk
up these ladders it will help you a lot
that that is machine teaching well to be
clear i mean
i think what tim and me are kind of
advocating for in a way is a mix of
machine teaching and the normal machine
learning because
we it for me it's really fun to listen
to this because tim and me also started
this whole thing with you know our
radar going off and kind of
being like
you know why are we why are we even
listening to this and why are we reading
this
but i think the point what tim is making
here as well instead of just like trying
out
every possibility in the universe and
then learn you know having it learn
that it needs to climb a ladder in a
certain way to get to the top
it's about kind of providing some
guidance and saying you know you need to
get to the top
and you definitely need to climb a
ladder we don't know which letter we
don't know what the most efficient but
you definitely need to climb a ladder
and then
you know providing that guidance is kind
of the machine teaching part
and then the rest we can leave to
reinforcement learning or
whatever form other form you find
suitable yeah this is
this is at the intersection of it it
just
it just it sounds like the intersection
of a bunch of
of things that so one is these notion of
inverse reinforcement learning
or imitation learning um
where you sort of learn from expert
demonstrations
right and and you assume you have a
bunch of of of trajectories already
given by experts and that's
you know supposedly those are good and
you're trying to imitate them as much as
possible
the second one is sort of curriculum
learning where you assume that you have
an expert that can sort of guide you in
which
examples are the next best to learn and
that's usually framed as
sort of increasing difficulty right so
first the expert gives you
easy examples and then harder and then
harder and then harder
and then the the last one is um
reward shaping and what you've described
right now is
is can be just classified as sort of
reward
shaping i guess because what you're
telling the model is
the ladders are good which it didn't
know before but you you need to
get this into the model somehow and you
get it into a reinforcement learning
model either by demonstrating it which
is this
irl inverse reinforcement learning um or
by telling it exp like telling it that's
a good thing
which is reward shaping so i i see that
i see the machine teaching angle like
that the framing of things
i i don't see the novel
like i don't see what makes this its own
field
so the reward shaping that's because
reinforcement learning has
a horrible problem called sparse rewards
which is that quite often in a game like
this you only know
that you've won if let's say you get to
a certain part in the state space or you
you climb to the top and so reward
shaping allows you to create
intermediate reward signals so you know
you could have one as a function of
height for example or you could have one
as a function of being on the ladder so
i can see why you would think that's
analogous to machine teaching but i
think machine teaching directly
formalizes
the protocol if you like theoretically
between
what does it look almost like a game
theoretical
um formalism of having a teacher and
having
a student and creating the optimal
curriculum
but here tell me what what is this for
this game how would you do that how did
you do machine teaching
so the all machine teaching is exactly
the same as machine learning
but you are introducing ideas
to the machine to the machine learner uh
which will be helpful
so i'm just trying but how do you do it
well
well just to take a step back as well i
think um and this is kind of
where we also said like is this like
this is this the marketing sauce or is
this really
the core of machine teaching because the
paper from simar really goes into
that machine teaching would be able to
fill the gap
of us having two sparse resources of
data science and so that we can
get domain experts which are not data
scientists and we can still use their
input
to help train um algorithms i think this
is
the part where we're also having a bit
of discussion like
you know again is this machine teaching
is this just a marketing term where does
it stand
i personally am also not sure yet
but i think it's it's kind of good to
mention this part as well
so i've been kind of we keep educating
myself for the last
10 minutes about you know the definition
of machine
teaching and uh at least what i can see
is the consensus is that machine
teaching
is the connection of human experts to
machine learning which is human
expertise being used to guide
you know filter the data set whatever
structure the problem to guide
you know so it's what we we used to kind
of call or or it's
it's an offshoot of feature engineering
right except instead of feature
engineering i'm going to be kind of
engineering the data set filtering the
data set
maybe maybe even structuring the search
in a certain way
but but it seems that the essential
point here is it's it's about
human expertise being combined with
machine learning yeah i think is that it
i think there are there are two
components to it so the first component
is what we were just discussing which is
quite simply um there is
a huge domain of data and there is a
model space
and what's the most efficient data
representation i can show to the learner
to help the learner learn what we want
to do and
that might not be one snapshot it might
be a curriculum and i understand
yannick's point that that's basically
um something which already exists in the
reinforcement learning
world the other thing is a new paradigm
of software engineering
which is exactly as you say having an
interactive process with domain experts
and modularizing
the you could call them feature
extractors you can call them modules
but rather than doing all the analysis
post hoc
let's embed all the modularization and
domain knowledge into the software
engineering process into the git repos
making it reproducible and so on
okay so from my personal perspective
okay there's absolutely nothing new here
this is just a repackaging slash
renaming
of things that people have been talking
about for a very very very long time
like 50 plus years in my opinion i
think yeah definitely it also connects
with with active learning pretty well
right where where where it's just the
machine that asks
for human input and so on but but i
really want to get to this like in this
example of the latter game thingy or or
you can tell me with the little little
ball balancy thingy
how would you do it because i like that
to answer the question the most
efficient
way for a teacher to transmit a solution
to the student is to give it the
solution
right so clearly we're so we're sort of
bound by
not doing that because that that would
be just trivial
uh so it's it's sort of it's sort of as
as keith said the teacher has some idea
of what's good and what's not good and
the teacher has some observation of
what's going wrong with the student and
the teacher somehow infers
which things do i need to show to the
student
particularly to make those mistakes that
the student still makes
better right but are we then assuming
that the teacher
knows the solution because i don't think
that's always the case with machine
teaching
that's correct we should achieve the
teacher
does not the teacher only conceptually
knows the solution because the solution
in a machine learning algorithm is a
whole bunch of parameters on a
a deep learning model so of course the
teacher doesn't know that
but it's very similar to teaching in the
real world if you're a teacher
at a school you come up with a
curriculum of concepts if you want to
teach
language you learn about tenses and
pronouns and grammar and so on
and you teach the students all of these
concepts because we recognize on some
deep level that if you just gave loads
of books to the students
they wouldn't be able to parse the
structure they wouldn't be able to build
a conceptual understanding so we give
them a curriculum of learning
now the other thing is that most
functions
like for example the the function of
natural language understanding
it's too complicated for any machine
learning algorithm to learn
even all of the data in the universe
would not train
a machine learning algorithm to
understand natural language
it's impossible the best hope that we
have
to have this data efficiency is to come
up with a curriculum
and kind of teach it in sequence
yeah so so that you you i i see i see
that
but it if you get down to the down to
the actual algorithm
so with this orange ball that is
balancing on this plate
i'm i suppose the choice you might have
is where do you start on the plate where
do you put the orange ball
so you can put it anywhere and you can
give it sort of any momentum that you
want
and instead of doing this just randomly
you can do this in sort of an orderly
fashion by observing
what the machine still does wrong right
so you start maybe in the middle
and you teach it to keep still and then
you go a little bit more out and then
you
you know teach it to have it back to the
middle and so on
so increasing instead of just starting
by just smashing the ball onto it
i i that's that's just classic
curriculum learning
and then i was wondering in the jump
ladder and so on when you say
you might tell the machine that it's
good to use the ladders
that sounds like reward shaping and so i
agree a bit with
with keith um in that it just seems a
bit of a renaming
yeah and there you know i think it's
worth mentioning
the concept of an of an oracle because
at least in
computability theory you know for many
years
they've studied things called oracles so
imagine you have an algorithm that's
trying to do something difficult like
the traveling sales problem or three sat
or
factoring numbers or whatever sometimes
you can consider
well what if i had an oracle that could
answer a
certain restricted question for me like
very efficiently like in polynomial time
does that then make it easier for me to
solve
solve this problem computationally so i
can't tell you how to build that oracle
but suppose i had it
you know what algorithms could i then
employ and this is a whole rich history
of
of analyzing algorithms that have
oracles and you look at like how many
calls do you have to make to the oracle
so in a way like machine teaching is an
oracle that says
you know should i pay attention to this
data point or discard it
and you can kind of ask that like very
quickly or in the case of actual machine
teaching you just never even see those
data points because the human has kind
of
filtered them in a sense so there's a
lot of ideas here that are very old
and and i think a lot of it is kind of a
repackaging and again nothing against
bonsai because look
execution is the name of the game right
you can have brilliant ideas
and sit in your basement all day long
and achieve nothing
you know it's the will to win that
outweighs the skill to win
and so if they put together kind of
these in a package that makes them
applicable to actual real world
industrial problems
great but i think it's a renaming of
concepts
that have been around for a very long
time that's true i think one of the most
powerful
features in this machine teaching is the
interactive nature of
how you create a model so there was an
example from microsoft research called
pickle
and it allowed you to build a natural
language processing model
um interactively and it's kind of like
you know we do what-if analysis on
models
you know so it's saying oh currently
this is the bias in your model
and this is the accuracy and so on and
it makes this process interactively so
you start off with a candidate model
and you have these features you turn the
features on and you can see
how your classes are distributed on
accuracy and then
you increasingly turn on features and
you compose this hierarchy or taxonomy
of features
and then you see well the accuracy still
isn't very good because i'm still
seeing my classes distributed across
the the output classes and then what
you're doing is you're increasingly kind
of
paying attention to where you need to
improve your model and then you're
making your model just good enough to
work
and you're creating a kind of
transparency on how your model works
which means you don't just need to focus
on accuracy and you can do
um bias and fairness as well for example
and rather than it being a post-hoc
thing it's actually part of
creation personally i would like to make
a separation between kind of machine
teaching as a concept and i think then
below
machine teaching there are many branches
i think project bonsai is a branch of
that i think
microsoft's luis is also in a way a
branch of machine teaching etc
um because for me i think bonsai has its
advantages and has its limitations
and focusing on machine teaching as the
core which i
would very briefly summarize as
you know in collaboration with machine
learning guiding
uh using human domain expert knowledge
to
guide machine learning algorithm in
whatever interactive way
or whatever vessel you choose and yeah i
find it really interesting to hear about
you guys saying as well like there are
definitely concepts that are familiar
with this
and i as i said before i found it really
difficult to kind of understand the core
of what does this machine teaching
actually mean and what does it actually
do if you take away all of the the
marketing sauce so to say
yannick what's your take on this idea
because you know we have complexity
theory in it and it's saying well you
you can have all of these different
controllers if you want for how we
feed data to the machine learning
algorithm and with passive learning when
we just throw all of the data
the complexity is kind of like a
function
of one over n which is the number of
training examples so this
this seems like it would take very long
to learn the concept we want to learn
active learning is slightly better and
then this
teaching is i think that's meant to be
constant time is it uh what's your take
on that
it's correct like so so so active
active learning is sort of can
ask this oracle but still sees the data
that it sees right active learning sort
of can't
can't choose which data it sees the
concept is simply the machine can ask
you
if it's not sure and then usually you
want to minimize some sort of
budget uh here teaching guides i think
that's exactly
right that's exactly what uh
whatever reward shaping curriculum
engineering inverse reinforcement
learning and so on
learning from expert demonstrations is
but you you see
actually on this very slide where it
says data which i suppose is the optimal
solution
the only data point the model gets to
see
is theta so that's actually transmitting
the solution
like this the very slide here is the
machine teacher just tells the student
the solution
yes so that's not a very arduous
learning process then
i mean i get i'm not arguing that this
is machine teaching and it's
it it certainly like it is it is as
keith says also it's very
it's probably one of the most important
things if you really want to bring
machine learning
especially something like reinforcement
learning into practice
into industrial applications it's
probably
immensely important that you can get
some data efficient
pipeline to run and that's also
reproducible and so on like
the entire teaching and input pipeline
how you build the data set
it seems very important in practice and
so so that's it's two things can be true
at the same time it can be very
important
very cool and you know the
so that someone does this in a clean
fashion is important
uh and it can also be very old this
theoretical framework i was showing
is is that does that have value in your
opinion
uh sure you can i think you can do you
can do all kinds of theory around this
and you can say as
as as we said before if if you have some
sort of oracle that can
you know sort of guide you and we all
know what is meant right the human
doesn't know the solution the human
doesn't know what parameters the
linear controller should take but the
human sort of knows
which examples are difficult which
examples are easy
where where is the thing still making
mistakes right the human can tell and
then the human can
sort of guide the machine uh to where
you know it should go especially domain
experts in
industrial applications they they might
be like oh yeah i know this is a corner
case
i know this is a corner case and here
it's still doing some
something stupid um so that's
and the theory around this is i'm sure
is very beautiful
uh but i don't i don't think
there's much newness maybe there is i
don't know
have you can you guys see my screen yep
yeah so
i've actually been making this kind of
point for years and giving talks to
customers which is that
you know machine learning is human
guided there's
it's not magic learning we haven't
gotten to the point yet where we just
say you know
computer make my business more
profitable okay i can help you with that
right and it runs off and just solves
all your problems and the example that i
always give
is is chess and this is admittedly a bit
dated because you're going to see it
doesn't reflect uh
alpha alpha zero but i don't have any
reason to believe
things have changed but the thing is you
know chess is a well-defined simple game
right i mean it's super simple compared
to the real world it has a 1500 year
recorded
history millions of recorded games and
not only that
it has kind of 50 plus years of computer
science research into
how to make programs that play chess it
was kind of one of the original
ai problems if you will and sure enough
you know not long ago we did reach a
point where
machines just utterly obliterate people
i mean your cell phone can
obliterate you know magnus carlsen right
and and you look at komodo there has
like a ranking of 33 93
on on a laptop versus him which is 500
points below which means he never wins
right
but there's actually something which
beats machines and this goes back for a
very long time
which is cyborgs you know that's man
plus machine
right so you have a person uh and these
are two of the world's
kind of experts and playing both against
computers as well as cyborg chess
kramnik and anand
and they sit there with a computer
screen that has kind of multiple
lines of analysis and whatnot but they
help guide
guide the game according to sort of
human intuition and strategic thinking
about how to beat the opponent that
they're playing against right
and they they can beat just pure
machines 85 percent of the time
and imagine like if you're in an
industrial scenario like yannick just
brought up right
with a factory that has many millions of
real-time
continuous variables that nobody spent
50 years of
of modeling of course human expertise is
going to play an essential role there
i think this is kind of undeniable and
so the bonsai framework makes it
more systematized easier to do that
easier to automate
that's great but i don't think the
concept that human expertise
should guide machine learning is is
anything new but
just on that though is that still the
case
if you ran uh deepmind's alpha zero
algorithm on chess well i don't think
the answer is known yet because
data like alpha zero is not open correct
you can't just download it and run it
yourself yeah you can i mean
you could implement it is it it's a
fairly trivial algorithm yeah
it's not it's not super trivial to get
it to work
um yeah the compute is the difficult
build
also the the defined details of
engineering but
i i recall i've i recall a lex friedman
podcast
from not more than two weeks ago where
at least he claimed that this was still
the case that humans plus machines
are still better than the best machines
well no but i don't know of anyone
testing it yet in chess
with alpha zero would love to see it um
my intuition tells me
it's probably still going to be the case
that humans can add value to to the
equation because
there has been a lot of analysis of
alpha zeros
games right and while it is obviously
obliterates human beings you know and
and maybe even a
is even approaching some limit of kind
of perfect play we're not there
yet right and it still has certain
styles and prefers kind of certain types
of games
and things like that that are that are
recognizable so but
forget about it suppose suppose it no
longer applies to chess
but it definitely applies to the much
more complex real world
i just want to know why because the only
reason that could possibly be true
is because it's a heuristic search
algorithm and we are
not searching a whole bunch of the
trajectories
if well that's obvious that's obviously
the case like alphago is
absolutely not searching every pathway
it's just it's using heuristics that
instead of them being coded by
a human being they were they were
discovered if you will
by some type of a you know machine
learning
but it's still applying heuristics it's
still cutting down branches
you know it's not exploring the whole
search space and the value that human
beings
have is look just let's all pretend
whether you believe it or not for the
moment that we're just bio machines
like up here in our head is a very
complicated
uh marvelously evolved
or however you want to look at it piece
of machinery
a nano machine you know a bunch of nano
machines working together to solve
problems and they've had billions of
years
to to achieve a very sophisticated
degree of computation
in a very low power footprint of kind of
20 watts or whatever
so it's not surprising that that machine
up there
can overlay some value onto some other
machine
you know even if it was like a weak
learner it still may have
it still may and that's what happens in
kind of the cybernetic case is that
is for chess is that people just have a
vague intuition that you know what
for this game i think we should really
just focus on the queen side attack
i mean for human beings we perceive it
as as a gut
instinct but what's happening there is a
very deep kind of
analysis that you just don't have access
to at a at a
conscious level it's just a bit that's
turning on in your head that's a result
of some
subconscious analysis and then you let
the machine which is much more precise
kind of take over the details
of working on that queen side attack
we're all saying the same thing actually
i feel like we're all saying that
machine teaching
definitely has value to add because it
is human input in whatever way you want
to
you know what name you want to give it i
think the only thing we're disagreeing
on is
is this something new or is this just a
fancy way of packaging something that's
indeed very old right and i'm on that
side this is a
and i don't want to say fancy this is a
this is an it's an actual
implementation and packaging of powerful
ideas
that are old uh and it's got some
renaming in there to make it new and
exciting
right um but but what bonsai does though
is it's like the data bricks of
reinforcement learning it gives you
a sure it's got the the ephemeral
compute auto scale
it has way you know enough detail that
gives you
the simulation so i mean it's it's just
kind of cool yeah yeah
well that's that's what execution is
what matters
not sitting around going these are great
ideas you know
executing on those ideas is the hard
part yeah and so bonsai's put together
an executed platform
to do this and but of course because of
the nature of marketing psychology we
got to rename some things
right we got to come up with a cool new
name come up with a
new language and call it inkling even
though we could have could have done it
with python or
json or you know whatever but uh that's
just part of the glitz
right but the hard part was just the
actual packaging and implementation of
it in a
productionized form so so even just take
automl
all right so as far as i know most of
the
commercial automl's are black boxes like
you don't actually know what their
recipe is behind the scenes
that's not true i think on on the azure
one
it's all open source no it's not it is
azure
well i just talked to the guys three
months ago and they said
it was black box what the recipe i i
gotta i gotta go
people um yeah oh okay thank you sir
cheers it's lovely meeting you this this
thing is nice i can't i can't stop
staring at this ball like the ball it is
it's so good right i told someone to
make like an animated
background of it it's so nice so
absolutely
put two up there what happens if you put
two this is the biggest this is the best
we tried it doesn't work
i i want bonsai now
does it doesn't work
so i think maybe chalet would say it's
not intelligent if it can't generalize
to two
just interpolating the data points on
the input so yeah
so in its current form it is still very
much a service oriented consulting
engagement it hasn't been you know it
hasn't been developed to the point where
it's just a
a little tool that you go and install
and run off and do your problem
you know you can try to do that but but
right now it's it's built around like i
was saying working on these very
difficult
um large-scale expensive problems that
justify
working closely with the bonsai
engineers to utilize and build the
system that you need with the platform
right i think what would be interesting
is to retrain it with
with can you change the model to have
the physics for two balls
or i think would they have to implement
that
because if that if that were the case
then the simulation
interface should have a second ball
right yeah
i would think you would have to write a
new simulator but i wasn't sure
how it was built there yeah because one
interesting thing keith is that they
the first version of the tutorial um
that there's a problem with
um sim to real generalization so in the
first
in the first tutorial the ranges of the
inputs are fairly
um they're softball you know they're
quite easy ranges
so in the second tutorial to make it
generalized to the actual physical
device you increase the ranges and you
also add another couple of properties in
so the size of the ball and the
thickness of the shell and
that apparently is enough to increase
the dynamics in the model
to make it generalized to the real
device
which is quite interesting yeah yeah the
the the shell thickness
influences its um angular momentum like
significantly
does it so yeah so a hollow
two balls with the same weight one that
has a cavity
will have a much higher you know
angular inertia or momentum for a for a
given
uh radial velocity the weight is on the
on the outside
because this this is illustrating the
need for domain expertise because
clearly you know about maths and physics
and and you
you would have just known to do that
because what you're doing is
you're not giving them you're not
telling the model what the solution is
it's domain knowledge it's awareness of
where where is the um
where do i need the model to learn more
about the dynamics of the system
and that's kind of a in the in the talk
i give on on
machine learning is not magic learning
like i talk a lot about that which is
you know these examples of look
you know human beings have been working
for tens of thousands of years to kind
of figure out physics and
and whatnot and in principle if you had
a deep enough neural network
and enough data it could learn all those
things you know it could learn
newton's laws somehow in there
represented in some
some neurons right but that's
that's not so efficient we need to have
ways to let human beings incorporate
this
sort of the product of our of our labor
of science to give it a big head start
and to allow it to use whatever
investment we've made in neurons to let
it use those as efficiently as possible
on things that we haven't yet figured
out and that goes back actually to a lot
of the conversations we've been having
on
you know invariance and equivariance and
and structures and topological learning
i think those are all
on the same lines of how do we encode
you know prior knowledge human prior
knowledge
in such a way that machine learning can
take advantage of it that's true but
then there is this bias variance
trade-off
so it is possible that introducing too
much bias which is what we're doing
can actually cause problems
sure but i don't think we're at that
stage
yet for these kinds of problems like
introducing the idea of angular momentum
is not going to bias the problem in the
in the wrong direction like that's
pretty solid
we know that one's pretty accurate
well yeah but that's because it's it's a
it's a physical quantity
yeah because if you put in some
heuristic in there
as we would do with featurization and
machine learning like
i don't know some weird oddity on the
shape of the ball or something then that
could have a perverse
and unintended consequence in the
dynamics of the model
and i i don't i so i this can be done
poorly
i totally agree with that which is why
you know we added some conversations
once with um i think ganec made this
point that
you know if you include the the idea
that the sky is up
then that's gonna cause a problem if you
ever get flipped upside down
you know now you're now you're gonna get
confused and i point out that
the way that you handle that is you
instead you encode an ocean like
the sky there is a sky in some direction
and then allow that direction to be a
free parameter so you have to you have
to allow the machine enough play
enough flexibility um that it can that
it can find the correct solutions
but we don't need to give it a tabula
raza we can we can encode
some basic concepts as long as we always
provide it like an out
you know way to get out of that local
minimum if you will
if it doesn't actually fit the data it
can escape you know with a with enough
evidence that it should try to escape i
think that's fine and tim
honestly if i were you i don't know if
it's possible but you have a couple of
hours of footage now of just the bonsai
thing like playing with the ball
i would seriously make it video and just
say like call a calming video of
you know machine trying to make it alive
or something because i could look at
that thing for hours
make it a live make it a live webcam
feed and then people can log in and
watch your ball balancing
yeah but you know i think you can get
like a pretty good amount of fuse
and put a little um put like a little
hair dryer or something that kind of is
perturbing it
once in a while to keep it going um
maybe once a while your cat will jump up
there and swat at it and that'll become
like a big
big hit yeah i was going to say the
norwegians pioneered this format of
television called slow television
and it's just um it'll be a video of a
cruise line they're going through the
fjords for 12 hours or like a
you know a train going those are so good
yeah it'll be just like that it'll be
it'll be therapeutic
i can play low five videos right where
it's like a really calming music while
you're studying and you
all you see is this person just typing
on their laptop for a couple of hours
it's amazing
exactly well it's just like in the in
the show silicon valley they had this
osprey cam
it was like a camera set up on an
osprey's nest
to show like how high definition their
their feed was and compressed over the
web and whatnot
and it was kind of like had like a i
don't know uh 10 concurrent viewers or
whatever for
a long long time and then some uh some
like forest worker employee was
was going there to you know somehow do
something for the nest
like make sure the chicks were okay or
whatever and he fell
down the mountain and got like severely
injured and the camera fell with him and
then it became like millions of people
are like watching
the feed he's like i don't know if i'm
ever gonna get out of here you know it's
like
a big
well folks it's been emotional
yeah i think we've got a great video
so yeah i don't think um i think
microsoft will be taking me off their
christmas card list after this one
we need to blur my face let's blur my
face and obscure my name
you know and voice so it's like i
believe the bonfires you know
[Laughter]
i i'm not sure about machine teaching
however
maybe